Boah, was ist denn aber diese App Store Scheiße? Kriegt ihr das in letzter Zeit auch mit? Hat dir jemand gerade ein Programm empfohlen, das wir mal testen wollen?
Fangen wir jetzt an oder was? Kriegen wir einen dramatischen Anfang hin? Na, keine Ahnung, ich dachte wir machen jetzt so eine Welle, La Ola. La Ola, die Podcast La Ola. Wir bitten jetzt alle Hörer nacheinander, wie sie diese Sendung jetzt hören. Ich will selber die Arme in die Luft zu schmeißen, aber eben nacheinander.
Ich will eine Irkla-Ola-Welle sehen.
Ich finde, ihr sollt noch mal so ein Song spielen, so wenn so ein Apple Keynote kommt, da kommt ja mal so ein Song. Dann weiß er, er blendet sich langsam aus, dann weiß er, jetzt geht's los, jetzt geht's los. Und dann kommt Filtschiller. Das macht alles ein bisschen spannend. Und außerdem geht der Song dann gleich in den Charts nach oben natürlich.
Tja, du meinst, wir bräuchten doch so ein Song.
Jedes Mal einen anderen.
Und wir müssen dann mit so einer Band dann so ein Deal machen. Wir machen euch berühmt.
Also beim nächsten Mal mit Coldplay.
Aber dafür kriegen wir die Kohle.
Machen wir sagen Coldplay, hey, wir machen euch berühmt.
Die haben schon ihren Deal mit Jobs immer. Jobs ist ja Fan anscheinend, der war wohl da letztens.
Von Coldplay. Ich frage mich ja, ob der wirklich so viel Musik hört, wie er da immer so behauptet, dass er das tut.
Da stand auch da, der war letztens auf dem Coldplay-Konzert.
Noch mit der alten oder mit der neuen, Niere? Leber.
Mit der neuen, glaube ich.
Echt? Na ja, wenn er schon auf Konzerten aushält, dann kann es so schlecht ja nicht um ihn bestellt sein. Wir knucken hier übrigens parallel, falls ihr euch schon über das Schmatzen gewundert habt oder noch wundern werdet. Die letzten Schweizer Berge von Toblerone, die immer noch Spende von vor zwei Sendungen sind. Jetzt geht aber hier auch die Schokolade langsam zu den Eilen.
Ja, da muss man erstmal sagen, Tim hat heimlich Teile der Schokolade an seine Familie verfüttert. Weiß ich noch nicht so genau, was ich davon halte.
Du, wenn da so ein zweijähriger Sohn vor dir steht.
Ich glaube ja, die Familie hat heimlich Tims Schokolade gefüttert.
Da kannst du gar nicht.
Und so wie das vorhin ihr gesehen habe. Genau, hat er ja keine Chance.
Achso, meinst du das ist...
Da hast du einfach keine Chance.
Er frisst dir noch die Haare vom Kopf.
Ja, wenn ich so gucken würde hier im Podcast, dann würde es kein Thema hier einbringen können.
Das ist auch, Hitler hätte viel mehr Erfolg gehabt, wenn er ausgesehen hätte wie ein niedliches Kätzchen.
Oh man, Loll-Nazis oder was?
Genau. Oh, I put a shirt right into your...
Das wäre doch mal was, so Loll-Nazis, vollgepisste Skinheads irgendwie von irgendwelchen Demos, dass sie irgendwie volldrogen irgendwo rumstehen da mit ihrem Baseball-Schläger und dann halt die entsprechenden so...
I accidentally loyknet your holocaust.
Naja, wie auch immer. Aber darüber wollen wir ja nicht reden. Das Thema überlassen wir in dem Rest des Webs, wo sie dann über alle möglichen Regeln stolpern können. Okay, also das ist die Sendung, wo wir euch von Neuigkeiten berichten, die alle gar keine mehr sind. Und wenn ich mir so die letzten zwei Wochen Nachrichten geschehen, in der Meketorch-Landschaft anschaue... Summertime, oder? And the living is easy. Also es gab einfach mal wieder...
Keine weitere Zeile sagen, sonst wirst du abgemahnt wegen Interpretation.
Gut, ich halte es maul. Aber so war es, oder? Also ich habe auch nicht viel Erwähnenswertes niedergeschrieben.
Aber ich habe eine Menge nicht Erwähnenswertes niedergeschrieben.
Das ist natürlich extrem gut. Haben wir schon gesagt, wie dieser Podcast heißt?
Wer hat einen Namen?
Mobile Max, haben wir schon gesagt, welche Ausgabe das ist? Nein.
Die 32.
Das ist nämlich die Zahl, die dransteht, wenn man...
Leute, das heißt, wir sind auch schon weit über ein Jahr. Ich glaube, das ist schon fast ein, ja noch nicht so ganz ein anderthalb Jahr, aber schon lange.
Mai oder sowas, ne?
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man sich so das Podfading so anschaut.
Not too shabby.
Not too shabby. Podfading. Kennste den Begriff?
Podfading?
Podfading.
Wenn man den Podcast so langsam runterdreht?
Nee, das ist, wenn der Podcast sich selber langsam runterdreht.
Tut er?
Naja, Leute hören unseren nicht. Also jetzt kann man natürlich darüber streiten, wie weit wir inhaltlich und vom Unterhaltungswert her hier die Fahne hochgehalten haben.
Also früher waren wir echt besser.
Es gibt halt Leute, die fangen damit an und hören da irgendwie auf. Ist ja auch jetzt nicht besonders überraschend. Ist ja mit Blogs auch nicht anders. Und auch bei Twitter-Accounts nicht wahr? Ich hab bisher kaum was eingestellt.
Doch.
Kaum heißt nicht nicht.
Blogst du noch?
Ich blogge, aber ich blogge halt jetzt mehr so...
Audiomäßig?
Ich blogge nicht audiomäßig.
Hattest du nicht sogar zwei oder drei Blogs irgendwie? Ne. Verschiedene mit verschiedenen Namen? Lunatic French und dann noch irgendwas anderes oder so?
Naja, es gibt halt das Chaos-Radio-Blog. Da blogge ich aber ja nicht so sehr als ich, sondern da bin ich halt derjenige, der die Chaos-Radio-Blog-Einträge schreibt. Wenn es nicht mal ein Wunder passiert und irgendjemand anderes was beiträgt. Und naja, bei Mobamex ist es genauso. Nö, eigentlich mach ich nur the Lunatic Fringe.
Wo ist denn da eigentlich bei dem, da ich ja von dem Podcast abonniert, für den anderen Podcast, wo ist denn das Bild da her, was man da in iTunes sieht?
Du meinst den Not Safe For Work Podcast mit Holgi?
Genau.
Na, aus dem Internet hab ich das.
Nee, nee, wenn man in iTunes den Link anklickt, das ist ein Foto von dir.
Ach so, das Foto von mir.
Und du siehst ungefähr aus, als ob du so ein Drittel des jetzigen Alters hättest. Ein Drittel? Na ja. Ob du noch ein bisschen jünger wärst und dir noch keinen Friseur leisten konntest.
Das war ein Foto aus dem Jahr 1999, glaube ich. Das ist ja gar nicht so lange her.
Da konntest du dir noch keinen Friseur leisten?
Da hab ich mir ein Jahr lang überhaupt keinen Friseur. Ich leiste mir nie Friseure abgesehen davon, aber da hab ich mir halt auch mal ein Jahr lang keinen Haarschnitt zukommen lassen. Und das sah dann irgendwann total wirr und verrückt aus. Aber das war so, weißt du, manchmal macht man so Dinge einfach im Leben einfach because we can. Ich muss mich da auch nicht für entschuldigen. Das war der Grund. Dann hatte ich auf einmal ganz viele Haare. Da gibt's ein paar ganz absurde Fotos von.
Das ist eins davon?
Ja, ja, das ist super.
Mobile Max hat auch so ein Thema, oder? Wie ein spezielles jetzt?
Wie jetzt eins?
Naja, aber so ein groben Rahmen, der über Haare hinausgeht.
Ja, Max.
Ah, genau, stimmt. Jetzt wär's so. Und iPhone. Genau.
Okay, jetzt haben wir langsam angefangen. Dann fangen wir mal toll an. Habt ihr gehört, dass der Palm Pre nach Deutschland kommen soll? Mit anderen Worten, das Ding gibt's dann wohl auch mit UMTS. Oder zumindest mit GSM.
Ja, bestimmt mit UMTS.
Ja, das denk ich auch.
Also damit fangen wir jetzt an.
Nee, das, glaub ich, können sie sich nicht leisten. Aber...
Das heißt, die amerikanische Version, das macht mit diesem anderen CDMA, wie es heißt? Genau.
Naja, in den USA läuft das ein bisschen anders. Hier haben wir mehrere Mitbewerber, die alle demselben technischen Standard folgen.
Aber das wird schon da drüben gerade, oder?
Naja, mittelfristig werden sie das tun. Das tun sie halt jetzt noch nicht unbedingt mit UMTS, sondern dann halt... Nö, die nächste Generation halt dann LTE. Long-Term Evolution. Genau, das ist dann sozusagen jenseits von UMTS, wo es dann so richtig Schweinschwirt schon mit dem Band breiten. Also das ist krass. Und LTE ist wiederum ein Konkurrent von WiMAX. WiMAX kommt ja aus dieser 802.11-Welt.
WLAN?
WLAN, Internet, alles dieser ganzen Bim-Bim. Daraus hat sich das dann halt weiterentwickelt. Und... WiMAX ist ja dann so dieses Metropolitan Area High Speed Network und so. LTE ist sozusagen aus der Mobilfunk-Welt heraus. Aber es zeichnet sich ja schon ab, dass der Bereich gewinnen wird, weil die da einfach sehr viel mehr Erfahrung haben. Und wenn man sich so die Zuverlässigkeit von Wi-Fi anschaut, weiß man auch warum.
Naja, wenn man den Preis sich anschaut, dann...
Welchen Preis?
Naja, was das so kostet, der Spaß? Was so eine WLAN-Verbindung im Allgemeinen kostet und was mich so eine UMTS-Verbindung kostet.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, diese Hotspots sind ja nun auch nicht gerade billig.
Außer man bastelt sich selber ein.
Ja, aber du hast es halt nicht überall. Ich meine, dass das, also, Wi-Fi ist meiner Meinung nach weitgehend gescheitert. Das ist halt der Griff Hotspot. Ich hab den früher immer sehr kritisiert, aber der trifft insofern ganz gut zu, als dass es halt wirklich so ein paar heiße Punkte gibt. Da macht das dann auch Sinn. Und, ähm, was weiß ich.
Also als gescheitert würde ich es nicht bezeichnen.
Warthallen, Konferenzräume, Hotels oder so. Da greift das irgendwie noch halbwegs, auch wenn ich immer noch glaube, dass wenn man selber ein Hotel hat, dass man einfach mal Internet anbieten sollte. Das ist natürlich auch nachvollziehbar, dass das nicht jeder selber unbedingt leisten will. So wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall WLAN und Weimax wird es nicht reißen. Und es läuft halt alles auf UMTS und LTE hinaus. Bloß dieses LTE, das wird ja eben noch eine Weile dauern.
Wir brauchen noch eine Alternative zur... Also ich meine, es wird auch weiterhin ein Breitband Internet brauchen, bis auf eine absehbare Zeit, bis die Angriter endlich mal vernünftige Tarife sich da aus dem Fleisch schneiden.
Ja gut, ich meine, das wird sich einfach von alleine legen. Wenn man jetzt mal die Situation von vor ein paar Jahren anschaut und jetzt heute, da hat sich schon eine Menge getan. Jetzt gibt's die Flatrates, jetzt kann man irgendwie für 30 Euro und weniger schon ganz brauchbar mobil unterwegs sein. Man muss sich keine Gedanken mehr darüber machen, zumindest wenn man die Grenzen nicht überschreitet.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite sind so rein formell diese ganzen Späße mit, du darfst keinen Instant Messaging machen, weil das gefährdet die Stabilität unseres Netzes und unserer Umsätze.
Ja gut, aber das reicht ja auch. Gerade hat ja O2, unser Pressesprecher sich dazu geäußert und meinte, wir würden jetzt diesen ganzen paranoiden Scheiß mit Voice-over-IP und Skype verhindern, würden wir einfach nicht mitmachen, sondern wir gehen da einfach mit. Die kleineren Anbieter, die da weniger zu verlieren haben oder mehr zu gewinnen haben, die sagen halt einfach, wir gehen mit. In USA, Quatsch, in UK hat sich ja auch schon einer geäußert, welcher war das nochmal, das war nicht O2, sondern ein anderer, die auch gesagt haben, Scheiß drauf, ja Scheiß drauf, hier Skype, wollt ihr Skype machen, macht Skype. Weil am Ende des Tages, merken natürlich jetzt schon ein paar, am Ende zählt halt einfach der unkomplizierteste Provider.
Ich möchte mal sehen, ob sich das wirklich so zerschlägt.
Einmal zahlen und seine Ruhe haben, richtig?
Ja, zumindest nachvollziehbar und nicht so ein Gurkenmiss mit das schon, aber das dann nicht. Weil man muss ja immer Angst haben, dass eben dann das nächste interessante Ding nicht kommt. Aber es sind ja meistens immer genau die interessanten Sachen, wo sich die Telekom und so weiter gegen wehren. Also innovationsfeindlicher kann man nun wirklich nicht rüberkommen. Das meine ich eben auch echt nicht, glaube, dass jetzt dieses Voice-over-IP bei Mobilfunk mittelfristig wirklich nennenswert da in ihre Verdienste einschneiden. Das wird ihnen tendenziell einfach erst mal mehr Kunden zuführen. Und mein Gott, wenn sie Angst haben, um ihre scheiß Infrastruktur, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, genug Daten zu liefern, dann sollen sie sie bitte ausbauen.
Na ich glaube, also mit Telefon-Tarifen jetzt mal ganz... Doch, das würde echt was gefährden. Da könnte Skype wirklich was reißen, wenn sie vernünftige iPhone und Android...
Du hast doch heute fast sowieso schon Flatrates. In dem ganzen Telefon-Kram geht es doch eh alles auf Flatrates. Was ist denn dann der Unterschied, ob ich dann noch mit...
In Fremdnetz zurzeit ist es immer noch... Also ich meine, die Flatrates gelten doch im Allgemeinen nur ins Festnetz, was ich exakt nie mache, da wo ich nie hin telefoniere, und ins eigene Netz und ansonsten...
Ja, aber auch das wird in zunehmendem Maße anders sein. Ich denke, das ist schon wirklich...
Ja, aber ich glaube, diesen Prozess wollen sie gerne unter Kontrolle behalten und...
Na klar, sie wollen natürlich, sie wollen das unter Kontrolle behalten. Das ist halt das Ding Kontrolle, Kontrolle, Kontrolle, Kontrolle.
Genau, Telcos sind schlecht im Los.
Genau, aber die Kunden wollen halt nicht kontrolliert werden, sondern die wollen einfach eine Dienstleistung haben. Und die wollen auch nicht groß drüber nachdenken und am Ende können die auch davon leben, dass Leute einfach sagen, hier gib mir einfach Netz in mobil und dafür bekommst du Betrag X und fertig.
Ja, das wird aber noch einige Schmerzen verursachen bei den Telcos, die sie noch abbauen müssen.
Und bei den Kunden wahrscheinlich auch.
Bei den Kunden sowieso. Dafür sorgen die Telcos.
Und dass man für Tessering extra zahlen soll, kann ich ehrlich gesagt...
Genau, da sind doch jetzt neue geheime Informationen aufgetaucht. Was soll das kosten bei der Telecom, das iPhone mit Tessering zu betreiben?
20 Euro munkelt man.
20 Euro.
Wollen wir da mal kurz drüber lachen?
Ja, aber man bekommt auch was für seine 20 Euro. Man kriegt 3 GB extra Datenvolumen.
Wirklich?
Ja, man kriegt zu seiner Flatrate noch eine Flatrate dazu.
Ah, noch eine Flatrate? Ja, das ist eine sogenannte Double Flat.
Vorhin hab ich den schönen Satz gehört. We put the Internet into the Internet.
Kann man nicht dann auf dem iPhone surfen, während man auf dem Rechner surft?
Ja, das verstößt aber gar nicht gegen die AGBs. Nee, das geht, das geht, das geht.
Also man kann alles weitermachen mit dem Telefon, während das Telefon nicht alles.
Du kriegst einen Strafbefehl. Sie haben gleichzeitig zwei Browser benutzt.
Das ist ja so, als wenn ich zu McDonalds gehe und einen Burger kaufe und die sagen, du darfst hier aber nur hier im Laden essen, aber du darfst ihn nicht mit nach Hause nehmen. Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß? Ich hab den auch gekauft. Auch jetzt schon die 3 Gigabyte. Wie können die mir dann sagen, womit ich die zu verbrauchen habe?
Ja, wo davon wieder so viel schlechte Presse kriegst im Internet, da muss die Telekom jetzt einfach mal dagegenhalten. Nicht, dass sie jetzt irgendwie gut dastehen.
Was ich ja noch knusprig finde, dass sie noch eine Voice-over-IP-Option dazu anbieten, die kostet noch mal je nach Tarif zwischen 10 und 15 Euro. Damit darf man dann sein Datenvolumen benutzen, um es auch für Voice-over-IP zu nutzen.
Die haben so einen Arsch auf...
Ich frag mich jetzt, bei welcher Option darf man jetzt auch Instant-Messaging benutzen? Gibt es da noch mal ein extra Tarif für, dass man auch einen Instant-Messenger starten darf auf ein iPhone?
Ja, aber nur Text, nicht Bild, ne?
Ach so. Nee, und dann hat sich bei Leo beim FSDK noch die schöne Frage gestellt, ja, und was hab ich dann schön von dieser schönen Voice-over-IP-Option? Apple lässt doch im App-Store bisher nur Programme zu, die über Wi-Fi laufen. Sobald das über, also ich meine, es gibt doch keine Voice-over-IP-Programme, die über 3G laufen.
Na, es geht ja dann wohl auch eher um mit Tethering sozusagen. Also wenn du dann auf deinem Laptop einen Skype startest.
Nee, das sind 200, nee.
Es geht wirklich um VoIP-Anwendungen auf dem iPhone?
Ich glaube ja, ziemlich sicher. Es gibt zwei Tarife. Es gibt einen für Voice-over-IP und es gibt einen für Tethering. Und die scheinen nicht in einem Zusammenhang zu stehen, sondern es ist ein expliziter Voice-over-IP-Tarif.
Ich glaube, das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, sich da lange drüber zu unterhalten. Ich meine, sie werden einfach losen. Die Frage ist nur, wird Apple jetzt, habt ihr das mitbekommen mit diesem 3.1 Beta?
Dass man plötzlich kein Tethering machen kann?
Ja, was bitte?
Diese Schummel-Methode über dieses Provider-File geht halt nicht mehr.
Ach, und dann ist bei mir wieder Tethering ausgeschaltet, oder was?
Tethering war, also das ist, irgendwie ist...
Wie will man das denn sonst einschalten? Keine Ahnung, wie ich das mache.
Ich nehme an, dass die gesigned sein müssen, wahrscheinlich.
Bisher waren die ja so angezeigt, diese Profile, so wie auch die Developer Profiles da so angezeigt werden. Und die Developer Profiles sind ja so ein grün signed und diese reingeschummelten, die waren ja so ein rot unsigned. Und so werden sie es wahrscheinlich regeln. Wenn die demnächst nicht mehr signiert sind, werden die nicht mehr angenommen.
Na und dann?
Na dann kommen die halt von Apfel und sind signiert, wenn es dann soweit ist.
Was heißt das, dass dann O2 auch ein offizielles Profil anbieten muss, oder was?
Vermutlich.
Nee, O2 gibt es nicht.
Wieso gibt es nicht? Das gibt Unlocked-Faults.
Aber Unlocked kannst du es ja eh machen, das ist ja egal.
Nö. Da brauchst du es ja auch so eine Datei. Ja klar, ich hab das gemacht.
Also bei meinem?
Das kann aber auch sein, weil es sowieso grundsätzlich noch nirgends eingeschaltet ist, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das grundsätzlich so ist. Ist das so? Ist das grundsätzlich überall ausgeschaltet, Tethering?
Also in Deutschland gibt es das auf jeden Fall nicht. In Amerika gibt es das noch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wo es Tethering schon richtig gibt.
Was, weil ich Hongkong oder so?
Ich glaube in irgendwelchen Ländern, die haben schon offizielles Tethering.
Ich würde mal glatt sagen, es gibt es eigentlich noch gar nicht. Deswegen ist es auch erst mal wieder aus und wird dann demnächst mit signierten Profiles irgendwie eingeschaltet.
Also wenn jetzt die 3.1 Version tatsächlich dazu führt, dass ich mit meinem O2 in einem Anlog-Phone keine Daten mehr machen kann.
Dann gibt es aber Hauer.
Dann gibt es aber Hauer. Dann mach ich auch keinen Upgrade.
Ich mach dann einen Jailbreak und dann passt mir das dann darüber.
Ich will keinen Jailbreak. Ich will keinen Jailbreak.
Ich will auch keinen Jailbreak. Da hat ja auch einer hier gesagt, da gab es ja irgendwie ein Hacker in letzter Zeit, der irgendwie ausgenutzt werden könnte oder was weiß ich, der dann aber auch schon gefixt ist. Jedenfalls hat der geschrieben, dass eigentlich dieser Jailbreak irgendwie 80% der Sicherheitsmaßnahmen aus dem iPhone irgendwie abschaltet. Das heißt, mit einem Jailbreak ein Telefon, ein Virus, ein Trojaner, dass der in Safari abstürzt oder was auch immer, reinzukriegen ist, ist viel höher, als wenn du es so lässt, wie es ist.
Das ist aber totaler Bullshit.
Nee, ist kein Bullshit.
Wieso soll das Bullshit sein? Warum sollte ich eine höhere Gefahr haben, wenn ich mit einem gejailbreakten Safari-Safari spiele?
Weil in einem gejailbreakten Phone laufen glaube ich die Programme nicht mehr in so einer Art Sandbox.
Ja klar, die laufen in genau der gleichen Sandbox wie auch in einem nicht gejailbreakten Phone.
Ja, ich bin dir zu sicher. Auch dieser Code-Execution-Dings ist auch nicht mehr an. Dieses No-Execution-Bit für bestimmte Speicherbereiche und so. Weil die müssen ja da so rumfuschen. Damit das Jailbreak weg ist.
Also ich hab auch die Aussage gelesen.
Ich hab die Aussage auch gelesen. Ich hab das Gefühl, dass in letzter Zeit über Unlock und Jailbreak auch eine Menge Bullshit erzählt wird. Also jetzt gab es ja zum Beispiel auch diese Geschichte, dass irgendein tschechischer Entwickler gesagt hätte, dass auf einem gejailbreakten iPhone keine Push-Notifications möglich wären. Da weiß ich nun einmal, dass das Gegenteil der Fall ist. Es kann allerdings sein, dass es nicht bei offiziell aktiviertem Telefon der Fall ist. Also es gibt ja diese...
Also wenn man sich aktiviert hat, hat man irgendeine ID nicht und dann hat man keine Push-Notifications.
Genau, also du dürftest eigentlich zum Beispiel keine, oder?
Nee, ich hätte jetzt diesen Hack da machen müssen, den du mir bei der letzten Sendung gegeben hast. Hab ich aber nicht gemacht, weil das würde eh nur mein Telefon leer saugen, deswegen habe ich mir das gespart.
Und, aber ich habe ein jailbreaktes Tele-iPhone und ich habe selbstverständlich Push-Notifications da drauf.
Ja, das ist wirklich Bullshit.
Und das ist ein Unterschied, ob ich behaupte, dass es ein jailbreak Problem ist oder dass es ein Unlock-Problem ist und ich nehme an, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass du am Augenblick ein bisschen so gegen...
Ja, jailbreak und unlocking wird schon immer durcheinander geworfen. Also in dem Sinne ist es natürlich recht. Jailbreak schaltet einfach Sicherheitsfeatures aus, sonst wär's halt kein jailbreak. Du hast halt kein Co-Signing mehr. Und von daher hast du einfach eingeschränkt, also du schaltest bestimmte Sicherheitsmaßnahmen aus. Ob das Ausschalten dieser Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nachhaltig und tatsächlich wirklich zu einer Gefährdung führt, ist eine Diskussion für sich.
Die sicherlich auch nicht wir unbedingt für ansocken.
Es ist unzweifelhaft, dass man natürlich Schutzmechanismen, die sehr stark sind, darauf verzichtet. Inwieweit jetzt dieser Jailbreak-Phone-Markt auch wirklich für Angreifer interessant ist, weiß ich nicht. Wenn es wirklich interessant wird, dann wird es auch ein epidemisches Problem. Und dann wird das mit dem Jailbreaking auch wieder zurückgehen. Also es würde sich dann von alleine lösen, das Problem.
So, habt ihr das mitbekommen mit diesem App-Store-Fuck-Up, dass jetzt irgendjemand, ein Entwickler, der sein Programm einreichen wollte, gesagt bekommen hat, nee, du darfst dein Programm hier nicht einreichen, weil du hast eine falsche Altersfreigabe eingestellt. Und zwar wurde dem gesagt, was marco.org, der hat hier Instapaper, schreibt er, und dem wurde gesagt, dass das Programm erst ab 17 Freigabe haben muss, weil, und jetzt kommt's, weil man ungefiltert Internet beherstellen kann, also weil es einen kleinen Webbrowser eingebaut hat, also sozusagen Safari gilt aus Apples Perspektive als ein darf man erst ab 17 machen Programm.
Weil der Content nicht vorhersehbar ist, da könnten also Tippen auftauchen, also muss irgendwie ab 17 sein.
Genau.
Was soll das heißen? Das iPhone ist generell einfach nur noch ab 17 oder was?
Laut einer Aussage, Programme, App, Programme, die im App Store auftauchen, sind nach Aussage eines Mitarbeiters, sofern sie ein Webview verwenden im Endeffekt, oder Zugriff auf Webseiten erlauben, pauschal erst ab 17 freigegeben.
Ich bin fassungslos. Ist das bestätigte Information?
Er hat eine Mail gekriegt, er hat eine Mail gekriegt, hey, du darfst dein Programm hier nicht einstellen, weil man kann hier, ihr habt es gesagt. Instapaper Pro ermöglicht, ungefiltert auf die Internet zu kommen, wo der Content mit der Major oder Suggestive Seam erhältlich ist. Die App muss in der aktuellen Rate für den höchsten Level des Content, das ist die Wibotex.
Nicht vorlesen aus dem Internet, schon gar nicht auf Englisch und dann auch noch schlecht. Also Zusammenfassung.
Ihm wurde gesagt, wenn du Internetseiten darstellen kannst, dann bist du ein Ab-17-Programm.
Das ist doch totaler Bullshit.
Das wird noch größerer Bullshit, weil wenn man ein Programm reinstellt in den App Store, dann kann man gar nicht selber eingeben. Wie viele Jahren das ist. Man hat eine Tabelle, in der man auswählen kann, ist das in deinem Programm vorhanden oder nicht. Und danach wird das automatisch bestimmt. Da gibt es aber keine Option für, damit kann man aufs Internet zugreifen. Das heißt, damit er zugelassen wird, muss er in den Programmeinstellungen eingeben, dass man in seinem Programm sehen kann, wie kleine Kinder vergewaltigt werden, enthält Titten, könnte Spuren von Titten enthalten und schöner Titel.
Das ist schon der dritte potenzielle Titel.
Und das, was er da einstellt, erscheint dann auch entsprechend beim iTunes Store. Das ist jetzt hier noch für die alte Version, die er ein bisschen früher eingereicht hatte, wo er ab 12 gesagt hat. Und, ähm, Mild was?
Infrequent profanity or crude humor.
Was man jetzt gutes Englisch aus dem Internet vorlesen?
Ich überlege gerade, wie man das am schönsten übersetzen kann. Also unregelmäßige oder milde......profanity. Was ist das schönste deutsche Wort für profanity? Profanitäten. Wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Profanitäten.
Ich google mal.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall komischer Humor.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist super. Kann man das beim Podcast auch anschalten?
Wir könnten ja Titten sagen.
Und schon sind wir... Also wahrscheinlich auch alle Programme, mit denen man Streams empfangen kann, alle Twitter-Clients müssen eigentlich...
Willst du noch eine E haben? Nee, nee, nee, ich muss erst mal zu Ende rauchen.
Laut Apple müsste sozusagen eigentlich alles...
Profanos ist ungeheiligt, gemein oder ruchlos?
Ruchlos. Könnte ruchlosen Humor enthalten.
Ruchlosigkeiten oder kruden Humor.
Ah, Ruchlosigkeiten.
Also nicht Micky-Maus-Humor.
Objekt oder Handlung, die nicht im Zusammenhang mit einem Kult stehen, die keine rituelle oder religiöse Bedeutung tragen.
Der Chat meint, Obszönitäten wäre die bessere Bezeichnung. Ja, aber auf jeden Fall mit Ruchlosigkeiten viel schöner.
Er hat keine Option, das einzustellen mit dem Internet. Deswegen muss er jetzt so dämliche Beschreibungen, die nicht in dem Programm vorhanden sind. Das ist ja auch kompletter Bullshit in seinem Programm. Das ist ja hierfür das 12-Rating, aber da muss ja schon harte Gewalt dargestellt werden, damit du ein 17-plus-Rating kriegst. Das heißt, er muss bei seinem Programm unten drunter schreiben, 17-plus-Rating. Er kriegt regelmäßig Anfragen von Benutzern. Wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, wie die Anfragen lauten, ob die laufen, oh mein Gott, oder ob die sagen, ihr habt das Programm gekauft und jetzt sehe ich da gar keine harte Gewalt, ich will meine Kohle zurück. Auf jeden Fall ist das echt mal...
Was heißt denn das? Also Webview. Also es geht ja gar nicht so sehr um den Webview, sondern es geht sozusagen überhaupt um Internet.
Es geht darum, dass man ungefilterten Internetzugriff hat. Wenn du...
Wenn das Programm einfach irgendwas aus dem Netz nimmt und das einfach anzeigt.
Sozusagen. Es gibt auch ein Programm...
Ja, aber was ist dann mit dem Safari-Browser? Ich meine, der macht das doch auch.
Hast du mal ans Telefon gedacht? Man kann mit dem Telefon, was im iPhone eingebaut ist, kann man Leute anrufen. Kann man Leute anrufen.
Kann man guten Humor belästigen.
Teilweise sogar Telefon-Sex. Da hab ich nur sagen lassen. Also nicht, dass ich sowas machen würde.
Ja. Nee, hast du noch nicht gemacht?
Telefon-Sex? Nee, tatsächlich noch nie.
Kann ich dir empfehlen.
Ich hab dafür's gehalten.
Sowohl die eine als auch die andere Seite. Ja, ich hab ja mal in einer Telefonsex-Firma gearbeitet, die eigentlich keine war.
Du hast mal in einer Telefonsex-Firma gearbeitet?
Na, ich hab mal für Beate Use gearbeitet.
Persönlich?
Naja, also...
Ich dachte jetzt so privater Telefonsex.
Also wir haben uns, sagen wir mal so, das heißt ich hab für Beate Use, das ist ein bisschen überspannter Bogen. Ich hab in einer Firma gearbeitet, die von Beate Use Geld bekommen hat, damit wir das tun konnten, was wir getan haben.
Die Villa?
Ja, die Villa. Die Villa, das Telefon-Abenteuer-Spiel, was eigentlich mal als Reperbahn-Live versprochen wurde. So mit ja und dann, weißt du, ziehen wir irgendwie über die Reperbahn und dann kommt irgendwie die Nutten an und plappert ein irgendwie voll und so. So haben wir denen das verkauft und dann haben wir irgendwie Pippi Langstrumpf Villa Kulterbund gebaut. Das war eigentlich viel lustiger. Aber war schon schön, weil es war halt so ein Umfeld mit eigenem Tonstudio, was ja dann auch mal wieder genutzt werden musste und so. Und dann saß man dann so beim Programmieren und 20 Meter weiter stöhnte es irgendwie über den Hof. Das hatte schon echt was. Kann ich dir empfehlen, überhaupt Porno-Business ist super. Also ich meine, dass das immer alles so verfemt und abwertend behandelt wird, das ist wirklich eilbar. Die Firmen, die lachen sich ja selber schlapp darüber. Also wenn du mal, dass ich dann mit diesen Leuten auch unterhältst, ich habe noch nie so eine entspannte Branche gefunden. Die meisten Schlips-Träger sind ja wirklich alle total verspannt. Dann gehen wir auf eine Messe, gehen wir auf eine Firmenparty, machen mal irgendwas im Business-Bereich und alle haben die Krawatte wirklich bis zum Anschlag zugezogen und nichts läuft. Total eingeschränkte Sauerstoffzuführungen zum Gehirn und keinerlei Lockerheit, nichts. Und dann kommst du irgendwie in dieses Porno-Business und dann merkst du, die Leute sind einfach entspannt, weil die einfach in der Branche leben. Da wissen sie, da muss man jetzt eh nicht mehr groß dran arbeiten, um seinen Ruf zu retten, da ist man einfach generell in der Schmuttel-Ecke und da lebt es sich dann halt einfach ungeniert. Und genauso sind die dann drauf.
Bis der Ruf erstmal ruiniert.
Ja, also das ist das Tolle. Die haben wirklich da eine Menge Spaß und Geld haben sie auch. Also ich kann euch das nur empfehlen. Und Telefonsext ist lustig.
Ich kann mal für die Werbung machen.
Was? Achso, ja, wir könnten, ja. Ich mein, wir suchen jetzt für Mobile Max jetzt mal einen Sponsor im Rotlicht-Milieu.
Dann müssen wir hier aber auch mal ein bisschen rotlichtiger werden, oder?
Ja, wir müssen ein bisschen Apple-Porn liefern. Was gibt es denn noch so für Apple-Porn auf der Liste?
Nee, aber falls ich das mal kurz sagen kann, wenn Apple bei dieser Darstellung bleibt, dass das Internet-Content ab sofort nur noch ab 17 dargestellt werden kann.
Das können sie ja meinetwegen in den USA machen, aber hier in Deutschland, bitteschön ab 11.
Dann hat irgendjemand, hat eine Firma aus Kalifornien das Internet irgendwie nicht verstanden, hab ich so das Gefühl.
Ich find das auch ein bisschen gewagt. Ich meine, jetzt können wir wieder in diesen Modus gehen.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass wir dieses Programm jetzt nicht mehr haben können, sondern die wollen halt irgendwie schon das ein bisschen family safe machen.
Aber mal ehrlich, was bedeutet denn das konkret? Das heißt, dass wenn dein Telefon Parental Controls angeschaltet hat und sagt hier nichts unter 17, dann kannst du es damit blocken. Das heißt, du kannst, wenn du jetzt irgendwie mit dem 12-jährigen iPhone in die Hand drückst, dann kann er nicht aus dem Internet zugreifen, dann kannst du das Runterladen von Programmen verhindern, was das Internet ungefiltert anzeigt. Aber du kannst eigentlich, kann man im Safari auch schon irgendwas einstellen mit irgendwie...
Dass Kinder kein Safari nutzen können oder was?
Doch, bei Safari kann man auch da auch so was einstellen, oder?
Das ist mir jetzt gerade nicht so richtig... Warum schaut man das sowas eigentlich nicht an?
Na, weil wir über 18 sind.
Hat mich jetzt unter 18 auch noch nicht so interessiert. Aber da gab es so einen Kram auch noch nicht. Da hat man immer nur ein bisschen gelacht. Aber man kann den Safari wohl ausschalten, sagt der Chat, der alles Wissende und...
Das geht bestimmt wieder in der Einstellung allgemein, oder? Wo eigentlich alles in der Einstellung drin ist.
Also man kann sozusagen ein Internet-freies iPhone... Was ist denn das für ein Quatsch? Das ist so ein iPod Touch mit Telefonieroption.
Bei einem iPod Touch kann man fast aufs Internet zuwassen.
Ja, da hast du auch Internet, da hast du weder.
Es ist halt einfach ein Telefon ohne Internet. Mit 17 plus gerateten Apps gibt es nicht die Möglichkeit, so Ausprobiercodes zu verteilen. Es gibt ja so dieses, dass ein Entwickler hat ja so und so viele Codes frei, die er verteilen kann, damit man über den amerikanischen Store, mit dem deutschen Store funktioniert das ja leider nicht. Dass man da Programme zum Testen runterladen kann und die er nicht bezahlen braucht. Zum Beispiel, wenn die ein Review sind oder sowas. Und das geht einfach nicht mit 17 plus Programmen. Und natürlich auch, dass dieses System komplett ad absurdum geführt wird. Also ich meine, wenn in Zukunft jeder Twitter client, wenn der Facebook client, wenn eigentlich jedes Programm erst ab 17 ist, dann könnte ich meinem Kind ja nicht zumuten, tatsächlich diese Option überhaupt zu nutzen.
Was, wie? Du kannst deinem Kind nicht zumuten?
Naja, wenn ich sagen würde, ich finde diese Altersbeschränkungen dufte und mein Kind ist 16 und der darf darum ab 17 Sachen nicht angucken und ich schalte das ein entsprechend in den Einstellungen und sag dem, nee, nee, das darfst du nicht. Und der kann plötzlich quasi kein Programm mehr nutzen, weil könnte ja sein, dass seine Kumpels über Twitter hier...
Ja, also wenn er es schon mal freigeschaltet hatte, dann ist es wahrscheinlich sehr schwierig, das einzuführen, diese Sperre, aber wenn du halt...
Nein, ich meine, das ist ja bei Instapaper jetzt der Fall. Also bei Instapaper sind die alten Versionen nicht unter dieses Writing gefallen. Jetzt plötzlich kommt...
Wir müssen uns mal mit jemandem unterhalten, der diese Parent-Controls tatsächlich nutzt. Also, wir brachten sozusagen mal einen Parent. Ja, Zweijährige fallen jetzt noch nicht so ganz ins Nutzungsprofil vom iPhone. Mein Kleiner verwendet zwar mein iPhone, aber eher, um es durch die Gegend zu werfen oder...
Oder einen Nägel irgendwo reinzuschlagen.
Ich mache mal kurz die Einschränkung an und dann kann man...
Wollen wir einfach mal bei Max einstellen, dass er irgendwie vier ist und dann gucken wir mal...
Ich stelle jetzt mal ein, dass ich... Jetzt gucke ich mal hier, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt... Was habe ich denn hier? Was könnte denn hier eine Altersbeschränkung haben? Wie Jive geht. Ich habe jetzt eingestellt, dass ich ab sofort nur auf Programme zugreifen darf, die ab vier sind.
Ab vier?
Ab vier, das ist die kleinste Einstellung, die geht.
Im Augenblick scheint noch alles zu gehen.
Was? Echt ab vier? Es gibt da eine Einstellung ab vier?
Naja, für deinen Sohn zum Beispiel, wenn du dem jetzt ein iPhone geben würdest, wäre eigentlich... Es gibt eine Einstellung ab vier.
Das ist ja krass.
Ach so, wir können ja mal Instapaper einfach runterladen. Ich probiere jetzt mal Instapaper runterzuladen.
Gut. Wollen wir bei dem Thema jetzt noch lange bleiben? Ich finde, das trägt nicht so richtig. Genau. Lass uns über Geld unterhalten.
Über diese Waffelgeld?
Ja. Also ich werde ja regelmäßig beschossen, auch in den Kommentaren zu unseren Sendungen. Gestern hatte ich gerade nochmal so einen neuen Kommentar gegen meine durchaus streitbare These, dass Nokia es ja nicht mehr lange machen wird auf dem Markt. Da gab es ja diese interessante oder so, da gab es irgendwie zwei Meldungen. Beziehen Sie sich auf das Gleiche? Jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal nachdenken.
Es gab eine Meldung von einem deutschen Bank-Analysten. Erstmal sind die Zahlen von Nokia da.
Die ganz offiziellen?
Die Quartalszahlen von Nokia. Die sind schlecht.
Die sind furchtbar.
Wie sind die denn?
Die sind so, dass sie einen signifikanten Umsatzeinbruch hatten. Und zwar ungefähr um 25%. Entschuldigung, einen Gewinneinbruch hatten. Ich schlage das am besten nochmal nach. Das macht sich immer besser. Ich habe mal so geguckt in die Historie. Das hat sich so ungefähr drei Jahre zurückgeworfen.
Die hatten schon ganz gutes Wachstum bisher.
Ja, die haben da ganz gut zugelegt in den letzten Jahren. Aber damit scheint es jetzt doch vorbei zu sein. Nokia schiebt das selbst natürlich auf die Krise. Wie soll das anders sein? Aber sie haben einen erstaunlich niedrigen Gewinn gemacht. Sie haben im letzten Jahr noch durchgehend über 1 Milliarde bis zu 1,8 Milliarden Euro Gewinn gemacht. Das ist ein ziemlicher Ausreißer. Aber auf jeden Fall so über 1 Milliarde bis 1,5 Milliarden Euro. Pro Quartal. Also nicht wenig. Das ist schon ein Laden der Geld abwirft. Und Umsatzzahlen waren, was ist hier so der Peak in den letzten Jahren? Meisten Umsatz haben sie gemacht im vierten Quartal 0,7. 15 Milliarden. Warte mal, ist das 1? Ja genau, 15 Milliarden. So, jetzt sind sie halt runter auf knapp 10 Milliarden Umsatz, aber halt auch nur noch 287 Millionen Euro Gewinn. Also nicht mehr so viel. Und der letzte Quartal war auch mies. Dann sogar noch weniger Gewinn. Na ja, gut, das muss nichts heißen.
Wobei das erste Quartal ist echt...
Aber magemäßig hört sich das eigentlich ganz gut an, oder?
Wieso?
Na, wie viel hat dann Apple und wie viel gepassend Gewinn dazu?
Äh, insgesamt jetzt als Firma meinst du oder im Telefonmarkt?
Nee, insgesamt auch.
Ähm, muss ich jetzt nachschlagen. Also Apple macht derzeit sehr viel Gewinn.
Aber auch noch einen höheren Umsatz, richtig?
Gute Frage. Ähm, ich schau mal.
Wir sind wieder perfekt vorbereitet, aber so ist es halt.
Du fragst jetzt die Quartalzahlen irgendwie nach.
Tim, wie waren denn die Quartalzahlen 1982?
Aber vielleicht nochmal diese eine Meldung noch zu Ende bringen. Also Nokia hat an sich halt Einbrüche. Das muss jetzt erstmal nix heißen.
Weil es ja eventuell jetzt auch für alle ein bisschen schwer wird gerade. Oder vielleicht gerade für die, weiß ich nicht.
Genau, und wenn der Umsatz sinkt, dann ist der Gewinnzusammenbericht ja auch nichts Unübliches.
Und die andere Meldung, die ich aber ganz interessant fand, das war ein Bericht von der Wall Street. Und die haben halt einfach mal nachgerechnet, wie viel Prozent des Gewinns im Telefonmarkt eigentlich an wen.
Der Wall Street hat es nur gedruckt, es ist von einer deutschen Bank, wie so ein Bericht.
Ach so, das war der Bericht, das war... Ah ja, richtig, da ist recht.
Genau.
Ein Brian-Modorf-Deutsche-Bank.
Und das steht, RIM und Apple machen 35 Prozent des Profits. Also holen sie 35 Prozent bis...
35 Prozent.
Hier steht 35. 35 Prozent des Profits im Telefonmarkt.
Also, die haben einen Marktanteil von 3 Prozent beide zusammen. Aber machen...
35 Prozent, ein Drittel des Gewinns, der im Telefonmarkt geht, nur an diese beiden Firmen. Und da muss man schon mal durchatmen. Und vor allem, es handelt sich hierbei um Cellphone-Industrie. Also, es ist nicht der Smartphone-Markt, der ja eigentlich ihr Markt ist, sondern es ist überhaupt der Telefonmarkt. Also, der Mobiltelefonmarkt.
Und die haben ja auch knuffig weitergerechnet. Wenn der Marktanteil auf unglaubliche 5 Prozent steigen würde, würden sie, glaube ich, einen Gewinn von ungefähr 58 Prozent des weltweiten Gewinns machen.
Also, ich würde schon sagen, dass das etwas ist, wo man sich jetzt doch mal Gedanken darüber machen sollte. Nokia steht da selbst noch relativ gut da. Also, die sind auch jetzt nicht so mega schlecht mit der Marge.
Sie machen auch Gewinne und so. Das ist ja schon...
Genau, sie machen auch Gewinne.
Die haben wahrscheinlich wirklich richtig niedrige Produktionskosten, weil sie wirklich auch in Massen produzieren, oder? Da kannst du echt so was von mit nicht heiß runtergehen.
Die verkaufen auch unglaublich viele Geräte, glaube ich.
Ja, dann kannst du natürlich einen super guten Herstellungspreis machen und dann selbst dann sie billig verkaufen, verdienen sie trotzdem noch eine ganze Menge dran.
Also der Marktanteil, ich hab jetzt hier keine Zahlen, ich hab jetzt nur so eine Grafik. Nokia hat halt irgendwie so einen Pound-40-Prozent-Marktanteil und macht knapp ungefähr 58% der Gewinne. So. Echt 58%?
Das sieht so aus an der Grafik.
60%, aber wenn dann irgendwie Apple...
Mobile Max, der einzige Podcast, bei dem Live-Grafiken vorgelesen werden.
Genau. Ich versuch das nur gerade so ein bisschen zu verstehen. Auf jeden Fall, Motorola ist definitiv nicht mehr lange dabei. Aber ich glaub trotzdem, dass es Nokia sehr schwer haben wird. Ich meine, es gab jetzt hier so einen Kommentator bei Mobile Max, blogg zur letzten Sendung, der mich nochmal drauf hinwies, Na ja, Nokia hat ja in den USA keinerlei Markt. Wie sollen sie da noch einen verlieren und so?
Ist es so?
Nokia ist in den USA faktisch nicht sichtbar. Also in Nordamerika.
Nokia-Telefone sind doch totale exoten Telefone.
Ja, der Marktanteil ist faktisch 0%.
Also in Amerika haben die dann vor allem Motorola oder wie?
Motorola, RIM, Apple.
Zone Ericsson geht glaube ich auch nicht so richtig gut da drüben.
Das liegt dann auch wieder an diesem CDMA, was sie da benutzen.
Woran das jetzt im einzelnen liegt, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, es ist auch so ein bisschen historisch gewachsen.
Die haben das einfach nie so in Angriff genommen oder nehmen können.
Ich meine, für Nokia muss aber eigentlich der amerikanische Markt interessant sein.
Ach, für jeden ist der amerikanische Markt interessant, aber trotzdem muss er erstmal in der Lage sein, ihn auch zu holen. Und das ist ihm offensichtlich nicht gelungen. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass ihm das jetzt noch gelingen wird. Weil die These habe ich jetzt schon mehrfach vertreten. Ich glaube einfach nicht, dass Nokia irgendwas in der Hand hat. Ich sehe auch immer noch nichts.
Ich glaube Nokias eigentliche Problem ist, dass sie was in der Hand haben, was eigentlich verrottet ist und was sie nicht loslassen wollen, nämlich Symbian. Ich meine, Sony Ericsson, da sind heute die ersten Bilder von deren ersten Android-Telefon aufgetaucht. Und Xperia 3 oder sowas. Das heißt, die gehen irgendwohin, die können relativ ok hardware bauen und nehmen sich das Betriebssystem, was ihnen gerade am besten in den Kram passt.
Das kann doch Nokia in einem halben Jahr auch hochziehen. Das kann ich so schwer sagen.
Das könnte Nokia theoretisch auch, aber ich nehme mal an, dass die auf jedem internen Meeting, wo irgendjemand auch nur auf die D-Com vorzuschlagen, dass man ja ein anderes Betriebssystem machen könnte, eher live von dem Rest der Manager gelüncht wird, weil sie ja noch dieses Symbian-Betriebssystem haben. Und was heißt denn das für die Bestandskunden, und was heißt das für die Marke, und was heißt das für so und so. Und wie viele Entwickler springen dann ab von Symbian-Telefonen?
Symbian ist tot.
Und ja, aber das...
Nein, ich glaube auch nicht, dass das bei Nokia jemand ernsthaft noch verfolgt. Symbian.
Doch, das werden sie noch eine ganze Weile ernsthaft verfolgen, natürlich.
Aha, und warum haben sie dann Trolltech gekauft?
Meinst du, sie wollen noch ein eigenes Betriebssystem hinten dran knallen?
Ja, Linux wie alle anderen auch. Das ist der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner. Man nimmt heutzutage Linux oder Apple nimmt macOS. So, was anderes findest du derzeit nicht mehr auf dem Markt.
Und davon noch der gemeinsame Nenner ist ja ein Unix halt.
Symbian ist einfach, vergiss es.
Ja, aber im Augenblick haben sie noch den höchsten Marktanteil bei den Smartphones.
Fallend.
Fallend, aber noch haben sie ihn.
Ja, aber er fällt in einer sehr hohen Geschwindigkeit. Also, die werden sich nicht erlangen halten.
Also, ich biere Wette, dass das, dass, dass...
Welche Bedeutungen haben Applikationen auf einem Telefon heute? Welche Bedeutung hatten die vor einem Jahr? Welche hatten sie vor zwei Jahren? Vor zwei Jahren keine, vor einem Jahr ging es los. Dieses Jahr ist es der alles entscheidende Faktor. Das Ding ist, Nokia baut keine Plattformen. Nokia baut Telefone, aber von einer Plattformsvision sind die so dermaßen weit entfernt, wie keiner irgendwie.
Ja, aber sie haben quasi endlich eine Plattform. Sie haben Symbian.
Ich...
Da fällt einem eine Schmack.
Das nennst du eine Plattform? Das ist ein uraltes Betriebssystem.
Niemand entwickelt dafür. Aber es gibt... naja, das stimmt. Aber es ist wenig genug, als das, um selber Angst zu machen, dass sie sagen, oh mein Gott, was machen denn die ganzen Filmkunden? Ich kenne da jemanden aus Hinterhulu, der hat extra für seine drei Nokia-Telefone ein eigenes Programm entwickelt. Dem müssen wir doch eine Zukunft bieten.
Ja gut, aber damit wird sich dieser Laden nicht retten können als die Number One worldwide. Nein, genau das meine ich ja. Diejenigen, die noch eine Chance haben, sind diejenigen, die eine Plattform bieten können. Also etwas, was auch in die Zukunft schaut. Und bei Nokia ist man auch nicht mehr in der Lage, zwei ihrer Telefone zueinander halbwegs kompatibel zu machen.
Nokia hat das Problem, sie haben was in der Hand. Versehentlich. Und sind nicht bereit, davon mal eben Abstand zu nehmen.
Das ist so, wie Toshiba jetzt eineinhalb Jahre keinen Blu-Ray-Player gebaut haben, weil sie ja vorher HD, DVD da irgendwie gepusht haben. Da haben sie sich eineinhalb Jahre nicht getraut, weil es ja auch beschämt, dass sie jetzt klein beigeben müssen. Und jetzt haben sie es aber doch gemacht, eineinhalb Jahre später. Und so ähnlich wird es für Nokia wahrscheinlich auch sein.
Bei Palm haben sie es nach wie lange, also ich meine wie lange musste Palm kurz vor der Pleite stehen, bis es hier... Scheiße, wie heißt denn jetzt der ehemalige Rubenstein? Nee, wie heißt denn jetzt? Ja, Rubenstein geschafft hat den Laden umzudrehen. Und ich glaube auch der nur, weil er mit einer extrem harten Axt reingehauen hat und weil Palm, glaube ich, auch ein relativ kleiner Laden ist. Nokia ist doch eine Behörde, vermute ich mal. Rein von der Größe her, rein von so viele Plattformen, wie sie nach Inkonsistenz sie nach außen auftreten. Was man so hört, wenn man mit Nokia-Wildarbeitern mal spricht, dass die selber von ihren eigenen Projekten gar keine Ahnung haben. Das ist doch eine Behörde, wo einer macht das und der nächste macht das und es gibt keine Strategie. Aber ich nehme an, sie werden sagen, Symbian ist die Zukunft und ich glaube, das glauben die wirklich.
Nokia erinnert mich so ein bisschen an Apple Mitte der 90er Jahre. Die waren sozusagen die Avantgarde. Sie waren irgendwie das, was alle gekauft haben. Sie hatten irgendwie einen stabilen Marktanteil. Sie haben super Margen gehabt. Sie haben unheimlich viele Modelle draußen gehabt. Und da fing das Problem dann schon an. Sie haben viele Modelle gehabt, die einfach, wo dem Kunden überhaupt nicht mehr klar wurde, welche Zahl und welcher Buchstabe jetzt, wofür eigentlich steht. Und die auch untereinander hardware-technisch und software-technisch weitgehend incompatibel zueinander waren. Wobei, mit Einschränkung bei Apple war diese Software-Inkompatibilität natürlich nicht so ein großes Problem. Aber schon für ihre Betriebssystementwicklung war es ein großes Problem. Diese ganzen Plattformen zu unterstützen, diese vielen unterschiedlichen Mainboards, ich meine, Performa, 60-00 und so weiter.
Das ist dieser Michael Spindler, der da gerade aktiv war.
Und das hat ihnen dann auch das Kreuz gebrochen mit ihrem Mac OS. Sie haben es halt einfach nicht geschafft, rechtzeitig eine neue Strategie aufzulegen und eine Betriebssystemfahrt einzuschlagen, der in die Zukunft weist, und wo dann auch die Developer wissen, ah, alles klar, da geht es hin. Sondern sie haben alle zwei Jahre immer wieder etwas verworfen. Und genau das ist jetzt das Schema, was du halt bei Nokia auch siehst. Sie haben verschiedene User Interfaces ausprobiert, sie haben dieses Maemo, sie haben dieses U-IQ, oder wie das heißt. Jedes Telefon bedient sich anders, jedes Telefon hatte eine andere Optik. Also natürlich jetzt nicht jedes einzelne, aber du weißt, was ich meine, es gab einfach eine große Varietät in dem, was die machen. Und selbst wenn zwei Telefone mit demselben Betriebssystem liefen, also eben dem Symbian, waren halt die Geräte untereinander nicht vergleichbar, weil so eine Tastatur, so eine Tastatur, das war alles.
Ich hab schon vorm, als ich einen N70 hatte, Nokia N70 war das ein kleines, hässliches, wirklich furchtbares Telefon, wo ich dann gehört hatte, dass ein WebKit-Browser drin hat, weil es ja S60 drin hat. Und nee, meins hatte kein WebKit-Browser. Warum, weil ich S60 Second Edition hatte. S60 Third Edition kam nur auf den neuen Geräten raus. Und denkt man, Second Edition, da gibt es irgendwie mal ein Upgrade-Paket auf die Third Edition. Was jetzt meine Mutti nicht installieren würde, aber was ich natürlich installiere, nein, gibt es einfach nicht. Das ist, du wirst von der Entwicklung abgeschnitten, in dem Moment, in dem du ein Telefon kaufst. Und das zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo alle schon von der Third Edition geredet haben, haben die noch Geräte mit der alten Betriebssystemversion verkauft.
Ja, stimmt. Ich meine, das iPhone war wahrscheinlich das erste Telefon. Das erste wirkliche Telefon, wo einfach Software-Update kein Problem mehr war.
Genau.
Wo die Leute das auch durchführen. Also ich möchte nicht wissen, wie gering der Prozentsatz ist von Nokia-Telefonen, die theoretisch eine neue Software hätten bekommen können, wo dann auch tatsächlich mal eine neu installiert wurde.
Und wenn man das mal gemacht hat, ich hab mal für mein N95 als Firmware-Update gemacht, für diverse Sony Ericsson-Geräte hab ich das gemacht, Informationen über neue Versionen findet man sowieso nur in irgendwelchen Hyperhacker-Foren. Die gibt's nicht offiziell auf der Seite zu sehen. Da steht nicht irgendwo mit der Version haben wir jetzt das und das neue Feature. Es gibt nicht die Möglichkeit informiert zu werden, wenn eine neue Version da ist. Dann gibt's halt jeder Provider eine eigene Version. Dieses, wenn du das auf einem Vodafone-Telefon installierst, diese Version, dann funktioniert dein Telefon nicht mehr. Und wenn du das und das da installierst, ist das ein extrem hohes Risiko. Und dann hab ich mir auch tatsächlich mal ein Telefon, nee, zwei sogar damit gebrickt, also dass die danach nicht mehr hochgefahren sind. Ich hab sie beide retten können. Aber es war eine Erfahrung, nach der ich mir gesagt habe, also ein Unlock bei einem iPhone ist leichter durchzuführen als ein normales Software-Update bei den meisten anderen Herstellern. Und ja, das tötet natürlich auch so eine Plattform.
Also, wie gesagt, ich wundere mich, wie Leute aus der aktuellen Situation ableiten könnten, dass Nokia noch irgendeine Chance hat. Also ich glaube, die sind halt einfach in drei Jahren ist das vorbei.
Also ich verstehe, dass man nicht sagt, also du interpolierst ja im Augenblick. Du sagst, es geht mit ihnen bergab. Das wird einfach weitergehen. Das ist natürlich keine gute Zukunft vorhersage.
Die werden einfach verschwinden von dem Markt. Gummistiefel. Wir können wieder Gummistiefel bauen.
Ich glaube, die kommen in einem halben Jahr oder so auch mit einem Android-Telefon, da die nicht bessert einfällt.
Ja, dann sind sie ja weg.
Wieso?
Nein, ich rede jetzt wirklich von Systemen. Okay, also die Firma, die wird bleiben. Ja, sie werden irgendwas bauen, so wie HTC. Ja, dass sie halt einfach Hardware liefern, auf dem irgendwas läuft. Und mich würde gar nicht mal wundern, wenn sie sich jetzt alle auf Android einschießen. Das scheint schon das beste Modell zu sein, weil es halt einfach nichts kostet.
Also ich behaupte mal, dass, was auch immer Nokia bringen wird, es wird ein Symbian-Kompatibilitätsstack beinhalten.
Also wenn sie das haben, dann sind sie weg. Sie müssen, genauso wie Pri, wie der Pri komplett mit der Vergangenheit gebrochen hat, müssen sie auch mit der Vergangenheit brechen. Aber eigentlich ist es jetzt schon zu spät. Also ich glaube, ein paar waren die Letzten, die jetzt noch eine Chance gehabt haben. Aber ich meine, wenn Nokia jetzt nochmal eine neue Plattform vorstellt, wer soll sich denn das bitte anschauen?
Wenn Nokia jetzt noch eine Plattform vorstellt?
Ja, wer interessiert sich denn dafür? Eine Plattform mit 0% Installationsbasis in den USA. Ich bitte dich, wo wird die gute Software geschrieben auf diesem Planeten? Wo kommen die guten Anwendungen her? Na? Aus den USA. Natürlich, es gibt gute Programmierer in Deutschland, es gibt gute Programmierer überall auf diesem Planeten, aber wir wissen auch, Softwareindustrie ist einfach mal USA. Und du kannst nicht ein System auf diesen Weltmarkt bringen mit irgendwie einer globalen Community, ohne in den USA irgendeine Bedeutung zu haben. Incoming Google. Na ja, Google hat ja auch, wo wir gerade so bei Android sind, ein Announcement gemacht, was ich ganz bemerkenswert finde, auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt zugeben muss, mich nicht sehr viel damit beschäftigt zu haben, dass sie jetzt halt nochmal ein Betriebssystem rausbringen wollen.
Ach, stimmt.
Ja, hast du von gehört, ne? Dann hab ich von gehört. Jetzt nehmen sie halt den Namen ihres Browsers, schreiben uns hinterher und dann soll das eben so ein Betriebssystem sein für Netbooks. Und alle schütteln mit dem Kopf und fragen sich, was soll denn das jetzt sein?
Wer hat gesagt, dieser Typ von Mini-Microsoft, hey, ihr werdet gerade zum neuen Microsoft, jetzt seid das?
Wieso? Wieso?
Erstmal, Waperware. Google hat im Wesentlichen ein Blog-Coasting gesagt, hey, eines Tages werden wir ein Betriebssystem haben. Haben irgendwie dreieinhalb strategische Partner genannt, mit denen sie das zusammen entwickeln wollen. Und es soll so ein webbasiertes Betriebssystem werden. Mehr ist dazu. Und nächstes Jahr soll eine Beta rauskommen, glaube ich. Oder nächstes Jahr soll, das weiß ich schon nicht mehr. Ein wichtiges Detail, das fehlt. Aber irgendwie noch so einen wagen Einführungstermin, haben sie noch genannt. Und mit anderen Worten, sie haben nichts.
Bist du da so sicher?
Also diese Meldung hätten sie sich durchaus sparen können.
Naja, haben sie aber nicht.
Haben sie nicht.
Und ich meine, Google jetzt zu unterstellen, sie sind blöd. Die Microsoft-Ware ist anders. Microsoft-Ware ist halt Vaporware bei Design, um einfach Konkurrenten aus dem Markt zu stoßen. Weil sie schon da sind. In dieser Position ist Google nicht. Google kann nicht im Betriebssystem-Markt was annuncen aus einer Position heraus eines Marktführers. Weil sie das einfach nicht sind. Von daher hinkt dieser Vergleich etwas. Also erlamt.
Na ja, es gibt zum einen ein Produkt angekündigt, das nicht existiert. Anstelle, dass bei Chrome das noch gemacht hat. Der war plötzlich einfach da.
Was muss man sich da groß vorstellen bei dem Chrome OS? Ich meine, das ist Linux. Das gibt's. Das ist ein Android auf dem rechten?
Nein, das ist kein Android. Das ist nämlich das nächste Problem. Dass Google plötzlich anfängt. Dann haben die den Faden verloren. Google hat schon ein Betriebssystem. Das heißt Android. Es ist ein zartes Flänzchen, was noch viel gegossen werden muss und viel Arbeit braucht. Plötzlich schießen sie mitten drin rein. Wir haben noch ein anderes Betriebssystem. Das werden wir demnächst haben. Was soll ich jetzt machen? Wird das dann kompatibel sein? Werden Applikationen für Android auch auf ChromeOS laufen? Ich meine, dieser Smartphone-Markt und der Mini-Laptop-Bereich fängt ja sowieso gerade an, ein bisschen zusammenzuwachsen.
Ich glaube, du denkst ein bisschen zu kompliziert. Erstmal, dieses Betriebssystem wird frei und open source sein. Das heißt, es geht überhaupt gar nicht darum, irgendwie Geld damit zu verdienen. Das ist kein Produkt, das...
Natürlich geht es darum, damit Geld zu verdienen. Ja, aber nicht auf der Ebene.
Genau, es geht nicht darum, Geld zu verdienen durch den Verkauf oder durch dieses Ding selber, sondern es ist etwas, was ihr Business-Modell unterstützt. Was ist ihr Business-Modell?
Werbung.
Werbung eben Internet. Worauf setzen sie insbesondere? Sie setzen auf Web-Applikationen. Sie bringen tonnenweise Toolkits raus, ihre Web-Toolkits, Gears, you name it. Ich hab den Überblick schon lange verloren, weil da wird jetzt einfach immer mehr kommen. Und wenn man sich halt anschaut, wie ihre Web-Applikationen funktionieren, dann kann man schon sagen, das hat was. Also wenn ich mir so die Funktionalität von Google Maps anschaue und wie sich das über die letzten Jahre entwickelt hat, alle Achtung, Dreck und Drob und Schnick und Schnack und irgendwie Hover hier und layer und schnell und das funktioniert irgendwie alles. Also wir haben einfach gezeigt, dass das sehr wohl geht und mit HTML5 und noch verschiedenen anderen Meilensteinen wird einfach eine neue Generation von Applikationen eingeläutet, die im Prinzip das alte Versprechen von Sun Microsystems erfüllen. The Network ist the Computer. Die Sachen sind irgendwie gehosted.
Was heißt Cloud Computing?
Cloud Computing kann man es auch nennen. Es ist einfach dieses Internet-aware Computing. Was ja alles seine Vorteile hat, wie wir ja wissen. Informationen lassen sich schnell teilen. Das ist ja auch der Vorteil von dem Android gegenüber dem iPhone. Wenn du so ein Ding in Betrieb nimmst, dann hast du halt einfach mal deine Daten sowieso schon im Netz. Dieses ganze Syncing basiert einfach auf einer anderen Denke. Und ich denke, dass diese andere Denke sich eben jetzt auch in diesem Chromos niederschlägt. Und dieses Chromos ist eigentlich nichts Besonderes. Außer, früher hätte man das wahrscheinlich Webterminal oder Internetbrowsingstation genannt. Das ist nichts anderes als eine Software, die du nehmen kannst, die du installierst und ab dann läuft da Internet drauf.
Warum nehmen sie nicht Android dafür?
Weil Android viel zu viel ist. Android ist ein OS, was Native Code supportet. Das ist für Computer gedacht, die nicht so viel Power haben, nämlich Mobiltelefonen, die auch noch auf absehbare Zeit nicht genug Power haben werden und darüber hinaus auch noch spezielle Anforderungen haben, nämlich Touch, kleine Tastaturen usw. plus eine Tide-Integration mit GPS und Pipapo. Chrome OS ist etwas ganz anderes. Chrome OS ist einfach der Blick auf, wie entwickelt sich der andere Markt, der nicht mobile Markt, also nicht der Handheld-Markt, sondern eben das, was so Desktop und Laptop ist. Da haben wir in zunehmendem Maße den Zustand, dass es sich um vollwertige Computer handelt. Die haben einfach die aktuelle Definition von Rechenpower, an dem sich sowieso jede Web-Applikation messen muss. Also etwas, was heute ein Rechner benötigt, die es in den ersten sechs Jahren gibt, wird sich als Web-Anwendung genauso wenig durchsetzen wie als Desktop-Anwendung. Bloß kommt es halt nicht, sondern es wächst halt sanft. Auf dem Handy ist das eine andere Geschichte. Da musst du mit deiner Software noch viel ökonomischer vorgehen. Auf so einem Netbook nicht unbedingt. Das heißt, alles, was Google braucht, ist Software, die ihr Web-Modell auf so einem Computer einfach zum Laufen bringt. Ohne Microsoft, ohne Native Code. Also ihnen geht es sozusagen gar nicht mehr um Native Code, sondern ihnen geht es gerade darum, dass kein Native Code mehr da ist.
Ja, das finde ich ja auch durchaus.
Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Sie wollen nichts anderes als Computer, Netbooks, ganz einfache Computer, off the shelf, die 100 Dollar kosten, hier OLPC-mäßig.
Die man nicht installieren muss, die am besten aus dem Rom heraus funktionieren, ohne dass man irgendwie Gefahr läuft großartig.
Ja, ach, die kann man auch installieren. Bloß du installierst halt nicht sehr viel mehr drauf, als die Möglichkeit, Internet zu machen und die Möglichkeit, ordentlich Web-Applikationen zu unterstützen. Einfach das Rüstzeug mitzubringen, um diese neue Generation von Internet-Applikationen auf diesem Gerät laufen zu lassen und Ende. Kein Windows, kein Mac OS, keinen Dreck und Drop, also keine umfangreichen, kleinsten Frameworks.
Da bleibt die Frage für mich, warum nehmen sie nicht ein abgespecktes Android?
Das ist ein abgespecktes Android. Sie haben nämlich einfach das Java weggenommen und dann bleibt halt das übrig, was Android auch nur ist, nämlich Linux. Sie nehmen einfach Linux mit Web und fertig. Und starten eine Chrome-Browser und fertig.
Aber anstatt zu sagen, wir bringen Android jetzt auch auf den Desktop.
Es ist nicht Android, es ist noch weniger. Es ist halt einfach das, was du so brauchst.
Wir haben das Keyword ja schon gesagt, Chrome OS.
Ja, klar, sie machen aus den Browsern Betriebssystem.
Hast du dieses Video gesehen, wo die neulich irgendwie durch die Straßen von New York gezogen sind und die Leute auf der Straße gefragt haben, was ihr Browser ist?
Ja, das hab ich gesehen.
Nicht was ihr Browser ist, sondern was ihr Browser ist.
Genau, welchen Browser sie nutzen. Die meisten haben gesagt Google. Manche haben gesagt Yahoo und ganz, ganz wenige wussten es. 8% wussten, welchen Browser sie haben.
Ja, und auch die, ja, Google. Und das sagten echt ne Menge aus. Ich meine, bei Frau Zypress haben wir noch gelacht. Gut, die wusste überhaupt nicht, worum es geht. Aber das ist die Wahrnehmung der Menschen. Für sie ist das, was browse ist, gar nicht die Software, die sie benutzen, sondern das, worauf sie gucken. Und sie gucken natürlich auf die Webseite und da steht Google drauf. Das heißt, ihr Browser ist Google. Und wenn du jetzt mit Chrome OS kommst, dann ist das sozusagen nichts anderes, als die Butter auf dem Brot und die Marmelade ist halt nach wie vor Google. Und der Top ist das Brot.
Ja, aber ich find's halt nach wie vor so ein bisschen...
Denk mal anders. Nicht mehr ist das.
Aber das ist genau das richtige OS für meine Mama.
Genau. Nimmst halt einfach so ein schwabbeliges Teil und dann läuft halt alles drauf.
Ich find dieses wirklich in einen Raum geschrieben, in ein bisschen Flash-Speicher. Und vielleicht kann auch niemand anders... Also dass man nicht zum Beispiel einfach diese Problematik hat mit Spyware und diese... Okay, die Problematik werden sie in irgendeiner Form immer noch haben. Aber dass es auch so ist, dass die Hardware auch so ist, dass es vernünftig drauf angepasst ist. Nicht so dieses Microsoft-Tink. Es läuft auf jeder beliebigen Hardware. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch schon Diskussionen darüber, dass ja Google auch sagen könnte, wir arbeiten mit ein paar Partnern zusammen, da ist das vorinstalliert, auch nicht auf allen Rechnern. Und die haben dann dieses Chrome OS und dann ist das wahrscheinlich perfekt. Also wenn du deinem Laptop zuklappst, dass der innerhalb von Sekunden schlafen geht und genauso schnell wieder aufwacht.
Vielleicht nochmal so als Blick, wir haben ja auch schon über diesen Netbook-Markt geredet. Und es gibt halt die Leute, die wollen da Windows drauf haben, weil das ist halt das, was sie sowieso derzeit verwenden. Das hätten sie einfach gerne in klein. Dann gibt es aber auch noch diese andere Welle, die am Anfang sehr stark war, die sich quasi an Leute wendet, die entweder noch gar keinen Computer hatten oder den Computer, den sie da jetzt billig kaufen und der Kleines gar nicht so verwenden wollen, wie sie jetzt ihren Desktop-Rechner oder ihren Primär-Laptop verwenden wollen. Sondern sie wollen eigentlich nur ins Internet gehen. Und dann gab es diese ganzen Ansätze mit Linux-basierter Software und dann hättest du einen halt für das Web-Brasen, einen für Instant-Messaging und so weiter. Aber wenn du dir heute die Google-Web-Applikation anschaust, stellst du fest, eigentlich brauchst du nicht mehr als den Browser. Und alles andere kriegst du mittlerweile in JavaScript auch als Applikation gecoded. Und genau das ist das, was sie tun werden. Das heißt, Google Chrome OS auf deinem Netbook und du hast out of the box alle deine Dienste. Du hast Google Voice, du hast Google Talk, du hast Google Mail, du hast Docs, du hast Büm und Bamm und was sie nicht so machen. Google Everything. Ich meine, sie haben halt alles. Man fasst alles. Das, was sie nicht haben, Google Earths Maps. Und das wird auch nicht mehr alles so lange dauern.
Wave, genau.
Das macht schon Sinn.
Also die Logik halte ich nach wie vor für...
Aber es ist auch nicht mehr als das. Deswegen ist es gar nicht so nötig, sich da jetzt so groß darüber aufzuregen.
Oh, jetzt Google. Dann hätten sie es noch nicht ankündigen sollen. Die hätten es ankündigen sollen, wenn das Baby fertig ist.
Das ist allerdings die einzige Frage, wo ich auch ein bisschen...
Für Android brauchen sie Entwickler, für Android brauchen sie insbesondere Endgerätehersteller, die das auf ihre Plattform bringen. Und wenn man da mal eben so ein Posting raus hat und jetzt noch ein Betriebssystem macht, dann kann man die damit schon mal ein bisschen verunsichern. Das ist einfach eine überflüssige Sache im Augenblick. Und das ist... Das ist meine Meinung.
Vielleicht wollten sich damit ein paar Hersteller mit ins Boot holen, damit sie gleich wieder ein paar Exklusivverträge abschließen können, damit die dann gleich...
Ich habe die gerade noch leise im Hintergrund abschließen.
Also Googles Strategie ist ganz einfach. Sie wollen die Leute wegbringen von Windows. Fertig. Das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen das, womit sie sich derzeit beschäftigen. Und natürlich gibt es einen Value-Edit-Markt, wo du halt High-Performance-Computer brauchst, mit High-Performance-Software, die wirklich lokal laufen muss und die nicht im Web so ohne weiteres zu machen ist, weil sie eben extrem installationsschwer ist. Das ist ja gar nicht so das, womit sie in Konkurrenz stehen. Sie stehen nur da mit in Konkurrenz, was Microsoft eben den Leuten noch als Client-Software verkauft, was eigentlich im Web genauso gut funktionieren kann.
Na, ich glaube, dass es gar nicht... Also ich glaube, sie wären durchaus mit Windows zufrieden, wenn Windows ihnen das bieten würde, was sie erwarten.
Wer?
Google? Google.
Also Google braucht genau das, was du gerade vorgeschrieben hast. Google braucht eigentlich, dass beim Hochfahren des Rechners eine URL-Leiste irgendwo dasteht, wo man eine Web-Adresse eingeben kann und dass dahinter sich nach Möglichkeiten...
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, wie Microsoft das handhabt....
nicht der Internet Explorer verbirgt. Und ich hab gar nicht an der Stelle vielleicht mal... Ich hab einen PC gekauft, um einen Linux drauf zu installieren, hat man das Windows hochgefahren und das ist nicht in einem Zustand, dass man das ernsthaft benutzen möchte.
Warum, in welchem Zustand war das?
Das war zum Beispiel in dem Zustand, dass es... Also was ich wirklich eine Unverschämtheit finde, das ist jetzt nicht die Schuld von Microsoft, sondern von dem Hersteller des PCs, da war irgendwie eine Demo-Version von Norton irgendwas, Norton Internet Security drauf. Also erstmal, man kauft sich einen Computer, der so unsicher ist, dass man eine zusätzliche Software braucht, nämlich ein Activieren-Programm, um ihn überhaupt erst mal nutzen zu können. Also das ist definitiv ein Zustand, an dem Google keine Trassade hat. Ich behaupte jetzt nicht, dass es bei Mac OS so wahnsinnig viel besser wäre, aber das ist Stand der Dinge. Und dann fährt man das Ding hoch und dann kommt da dieses Norton Internet Security und Norton Internet Security fragt dich, hey, hast du Lust für ein Jahr kostenlos Norton Internet Security zu probieren? Soweit eine absolut legitime Frage. Das Problem ist bloß, dass es keine Nein-Antwort-Möglichkeit auf diese Frage gibt. Es gibt nur ein Ja. Da geht ein Fenster auf.
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Da geht ein Fenster auf. Das Fenster hat keine Closebox.
Du musst Ja klicken.
Du kannst das Fenster minimieren.
Das ist konsequent.
Man kann das Fenster minimieren. Man kann bestimmt auch irgendwie, ich hab es soweit nicht ausprobiert, man kann bestimmt auch in einer Software-Einstellung das irgendwie deinstallieren oder Windows-Registery abschalten und weiß ja Teufel was. Aber wenn ich als Nullerfahrung mit irgendwas habe, davor sitze, dann ist da nur ein Ja-Button. Und wenn ich den klicke, kommt als nächstes die Abfrage nach meiner E-Mail-Adresse. Und das war der Punkt, wo ich dann gesagt habe, ne, jetzt ist wirklich mal Schluss. Und weil ich wusste, dass ich dieses Windows nicht benötige, die ich sowieso bald löschen würde, habe ich das Fenster einfach für die dreieinhalb Sachen, die ich machen wollte minimiert. Aber das finde ich ist... Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Aber das finde ich wirklich mal... Ja, das kann ich verstehen, dass Google daran was ändern möchte. Weil wenn man sich heutzutage so ein PC kauft, kann man damit erst mal eine Menge machen, nur nicht wirklich leicht ins Internet kommen. Und das sollte... Daran will Google definitiv was ändern.
Klar, natürlich. Ich meine, es geht gar nicht mehr nur leicht ins Internet gehen. Es geht überhaupt darum, einfach in dem Maße am Internet teilnehmen zu können, wie Google das eben gerne hätte. Sprich Standards zu unterstützen. Das ist halt einfach mit Internet Explorer nicht der Fall. Na ja, gut. Das müssen wir jetzt auch gar nicht weiter diskutieren, oder? Ich hätte noch...
Aber ich würde es gar nicht so schlecht finden, wenn da ein OS kommt, wo nichts kaputt gehen kann. Was so funktioniert wie ein Taschenrechner. Weißt du, so im ROM. So wie ein 64er, schaltest eines da. Machst aus, machst alles wieder da.
Genau, darum geht es.
So wie ein iPhone.
Das ist nicht so schlecht, ich finde das gut.
Chrome ist halt Android. Hat das theoretisch auch?
Ja, aber es ist halt optimiert auf eine spezielle Gattung von Geräten. Nämlich die, die du in der Hand hältst. Aber ich wiederhole mich.
Ich bin mal gespannt. Acer hat ja angekündigt. Mal sehen, ob sie das jemals machen. Mal sehen, wie es darauf läuft, Netbooks mit Android darauf anzubieten. Und dann werden wir sehen, wie gut es auf einem Netbook läuft. Und ob es das vielleicht sogar schon ist, was man sich unter Chrome OS vorstellen würde.
Das könnte der Grund sein, warum sie Chrome OS jetzt schon ankündigen.
Damit nicht so viele Netbook-Hersteller auf Android gehen. Aber warum sollten sie ein Problem damit haben?
Weil sie Web-Applikationen pushen wollen. Ihnen geht es darum, dass die Leute Applikationen, die aus dem Web kommen, als die normalen Applikationen ansehen.
Das machen ja viele Leute auch schon.
Ja, aber es können nicht genug sein und jedes Prozent, die noch dazukommen, sind für Google zu bearbeitendes Terrain, wo sie ihre Werbung platzieren können und ihre andere Schottung machen können.
Ja, aber was sie ja Problemen ausmachen könnten, sie könnten ja sagen, ok, sobald Android auf einem Display läuft mit der und der Größe, geht der Browser, bietet dann plötzlich vernünftige Taps und weiß der Teufel was.
Ja, aber sie haben nicht so ein großes Interesse daran, ein zweites API zu pushen. Das pushen sie für diese bestimmte Gerätegeneration. Hier Java, hier Native Code, hier schnell auf dieser langsamen Hardware, hier die Integration mit GPS, hier die Integration mit komplexen Eingabesystemen. Aber wenn das Ding eine Tastatur hat und eine Maus, dann arbeiten die Leute anders damit. Das ist im Prinzip dieselbe Unterscheidung, die Apple auch macht. Apple hat das iPhone OS, das ist halt für Dinge, die so sind wie das iPhone und sie haben das Mac OS, das ist für die Geräte mit Tastatur und Maus. Und die haben einen vollkommen anderen Ansatz. Nur das Apple natürlich auch noch dort eine kleine Bibliothek mit sich rumschlägt und quasi rich ist und Google das eben nicht hat und einfach sagt, brauchen wir auch nicht, wir gehen da einfach ins Web. Du musst telefonieren?
Nee, ich hab während der Sendung... Nein, nein, nein, nein. Na gut, lass uns...
Ich glaube, wir haben da jetzt alles zugesagt, oder? Ich hätte noch ausnahmsweise mal Programme zu empfehlen. Und zu besprechen. Zwar nur iPhone-Programme. Aber immerhin. Aber ich hab ja auch, wie so viele, viele Programme installiert. Und ich bin dann immer wieder erstaunt, wenn ich dann tatsächlich mal eins von denen auch wirklich benutzen kann. Weil manchmal kauft man die sicher mal so einer bestimmten Erwartung, denkt sie, oh, das ist ja ein cooles Konzept und so. Und da könnte ich mir vorstellen, das. Und dann tritt dieser Fall aber irgendwie nicht so richtig ein. Und jetzt hatte ich aber diesen Fall.
Das ist das Problem der Early Adopter, ne?
Das ist das Problem der Early Adopter, aber da leide ich jetzt auch nicht besonders drunter, weil das ist natürlich, so ist das halt, nicht? Man testet das eben und dann klappt's oder es klappt nicht.
Was hast du denn in der Richtung gekauft?
Na ja, schon vor längerer Zeit ist mir ein Programm in den Fokus gekommen, das heißt GoCalc. Heißt das GoCalc? Erstens ist es glaube ich anders, dann haben sie jetzt einen GoCalc umbenannt, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie es ursprünglich ist.
Nach einer Tabellenkalkulation.
Ja, ist es nicht, aber es macht etwas Ähnliches. Und GoCalc ist nämlich ein Programm, in dem du dir Formeln bookmarken kannst, sozusagen, also bookmarken ist nicht der richtige Begriff, sondern du kannst dir halt Formeln anlegen. Formeln, die Eingabe- und Ausgabewerte haben. Das heißt, du hast verschiedene Variablen, die du einstellen kannst und wenn du so eine Variable anlegst, dann hast du auch gleich ein User-Interface dafür. Also entweder gibst du sie direkt ein in so ein Textfeld oder du hast so einen Slider dafür und kannst dann sagen, in welchen Steps das gehen soll und was dein Minimum und dein Maximum ist für bestimmte Werte. Und dann kannst du bestimmte Results definieren und dann gibt es halt eine Formel, die das eben quasi diesen mathematischen Bezug herstellt. Das Ding kommt serienmäßig schon mit einer ganzen Reihe von Formeln. Das weiß ich. Kannst deinen Body-Mass-Index ausrechnen und... Taschenrechner für doof oder wie? Manchmal zückst du deinen Taschenrechner und es gibt so Sachen, die du immer wieder mal ausrechnen willst. Du tappst dich eigentlich dabei, dass du... Genau, Mehrwertsteuer. Das war nämlich jetzt auch genau das Ding, wofür ich das verwendet habe.
Damit man schneller klicken kann.
Ich habe nämlich meinen Jahresabschluss gemacht für 2008 und dann hast du tonnenweise so Belege, wo du weißt, was die enthaltene Mehrwertsteuer ist, aber nur Bruttobeträge ausgeführt sind. Du möchtest aber dann mal eben schnell in deine Tabellenkalkulation die Netto- und die Mehrwertsteuer-Beträge separat ausführen. Was machst du dann? Dann habe ich dieses Gokalt genommen, habe mir einfach so eine einfache Mehrwertsteuer- ausrechnende Formel da reingetippert und dann Taxibelege sind so das beste Beispiel. Du hast da irgendwie so Brutto, la la la, sie sind gefahren für 20 Euro, 7% Mehrwertsteuer.
Du gibst deine Zahl in deine Standardformel und dann zack.
Genau, ich habe dann einfach auf dem iPhone einmal irgendwie den Prozentslider auf 7% Mehrwertsteuer gemacht und dann einfach immer den Betrag, der auf der Taxi-Quittung drauf stand, den habe ich dann schnell eingegeben. Also ich habe auch einen Slider für ganz zahlige Dinge gemacht, aber manchmal sind es ja auch Komma irgendwas. So, und dann hat er mir sozusagen instantan in dem Moment immer gleich den enthaltenen Netto-Betrag und den enthaltenen Steuerbetrag einfach angezeigt, sodass ich den dann halt auf meinem Mac direkt eingeben konnte. Und das ist eigentlich eine wirklich schöne Anwendung. Vor allem, ich hatte meinen Rechner frei. Ja, also erst habe ich mit dem Taschenrechner auf dem Rechner gearbeitet, zwar dann doof, weil ich immer hin und her musste, und dann fiel mir auf, man, du hast doch das Teil. Und gerade solche Rechnungen, wo du irgendwie zu Ursprungspreisen kommst, oder was weiß ich, in anderen Ländern hast du ja noch das Problem, dass du so Tipp berechnen musst zum Beispiel. Du bist irgendwie sechs Personen und so und so viel.
Warum muss man eigentlich Tipp berechnen? Warum gibt es die ganzen Tipp-Berechnungsprogramme?
Weil es halt in anderen Ländern so ist, dass du eben nur Netto-Preise kriegst. Netto-Preise plus Steuer plus Tipp.
Und da gibt es halt so Tipps, so zehn Prozent und dann zahlen ja auch genau die zehn Prozent.
Und die Steuer, die lokale, musst du auch noch draufrechnen, die dann jeder Region anders ist.
Die musst du selber draufrechnen.
Nee, die steht auf der Rechner.
Nee, aber wenn du halt selber mal wissen willst, was du am Ende eigentlich bezahlen musst und ob du genug Geld dabei hast, kommst du nur mit den Preisen, die auf der Speisekarte stehen, nicht weit. Wenn da steht irgendwie zehn kanadische Dollar, dann sind das zehn kanadische Dollar netto plus die Local Tax plus die Governmental Tax. Also es gibt eine lokale und eine globale Umsatzsteuer plus der Tipp, der auch noch mal so 10 bis 15 Prozent ist.
Also Trinkgeld ist extrem wichtig, weil die Kellner teilweise in den Ländern gar keinen normalen Lohn kriegen. Genau. Nur sehr, sehr wenig und darum du mindestens so 10 bis 15 Prozent draufknallen musst. Also die gucken nicht echt schief an, wenn du ein Euro Trinkgeld gibst bei einem relativ kleinen Betrag, dann wirst du ja schon behandelt, als ob du ein kleiner Gott wärst. Und in New York ging das so, da bist du wirklich immer schief angeguckt worden, wenn du nicht genug Trinkgeld hast.
Fucking Europeans sagen sie dann, oder fucking Germans.
Genau, so. Und dementsprechend gibt es hier auch, kann ich auch mal kurz zeigen, den höre ich natürlich nicht, da gibt es die Kategorie Dining Out, Tippin, und dann hast du halt hier so fertige Formulen, was kostet irgendwie das Meal, und du gibst halt hier einen. Ich hab irgendwie, was weiß ich, 113 Dollar, zack, bumm. Dann sagst du halt, wie viel Prozent Tipp du hast, in diesem Fall 10 Prozent, wie viele Leute, und dann rechnet der das halt einfach aus und verteilt dann eben auch gleich, wer wie viel zu bezahlen hat. Also solche Sachen. Dafür ist das eigentlich ein ganz cooles Tool. Also wer da so Ideen hat oder was weiß ich, so goldenen Schnitt ausrechnen oder einfach so bestimmte, immer wiederkehrende Berechnungen.
Formeln.
Ist ein schönes Ding. Unser Stream ist tot, heißt es da.
Schon wieder?
Nee, da haben schon welche gesagt, er geht wieder.
Ja, bei manchen ist es so, bei manchen ist es so. Ich kann leider nichts dafür, aber irgendwann werde ich das hier.
Also ich hab ja die letzte Woche ordentlich Flight Control gespielt. Muss ja nochmal empfehlen, haben sich auch schon viele Leute bedankt, dass es ja so süchtig macht, das Spiel. Und ich muss jetzt verkünden, habe ich nämlich noch nicht gemacht. Ich bin jetzt Testpilot und habe 535 Punkte.
Das ist viel?
Ja, 535 dauert schon noch. Ich glaube, ich habe mal gemessen mit einem Kumpel, man macht so 40 Punkte die Minute. Wir wollten mal wissen, wie lange es dauert, wenn Leute da, die angeblich 22.000 Punkte haben, wie lange die da gespielt haben müssen. Aber ich finde 535 ist schon gar nicht so schlecht. Aber dieses Cloud Sale, weil die haben ein ganz cooles Highscore-Management, da wird angezeigt, wie viele Punkte die Leute in deiner Nähe haben. Also du musst dich gar nicht so weltweit vergleichen, sondern guckst sozusagen, wie viele es in der Nähe sind. Ich bin immer noch bei 0 und 1 Meilen, wo schon die nächsten Leute mit gleichgroßer Highscore kommen. Also das ist gar nicht so leicht bei diesem Spiel, was bestimmt mehr als eine Million Leute runtergeladen haben, irgendwie eine Highscore zu machen, die mal ein bisschen besser ist als der Rest. Aber ich bin in den Top 4 Prozent. Was aber auch mindestens 40.000 Leute sind, also bei einer Million.
Also ich hab's mir zwar gekauft, geladen, aber das kostet doch Geld. Wie hast du das eigentlich bekommen dann?
Na, hab ich dir erzählt. Ich war in Bamberg und wir hatten lange Weile, wollten ein bisschen zocken und dann hab ich gedacht, können wir ja schon mal 80 Cent ausgeben. Im Urlaub bin ich immer ein bisschen ausgebefreudiger, natürlich in Ausnahmesituationen.
Verstehe, dann gibst du auch mal 80 Cent aus.
Nein, der leuchtet gerade nicht. Er ist kaputt.
Ja, dann kam ja ein Programm auf dem iPhone raus, wo ich lange drauf gewartet habe und ich bin ja ziemlicher Spiele-Agnostiker, aber es gibt so ein paar Spiele. Bombs?
Really?
Ja, Bombs gibt es jetzt auf dem iPhone.
Habe ich mir auch sofort gekauft, habe es aber noch nicht, also ich hab noch nicht mal so eine...
Ja, die Zwischenbilanz ist auch wirklich vernichtend. Also es macht zwar einen sehr guten Eindruck, aber es bombt wie Sau, es ist langsam, es nimmt Touches irgendwie nicht so flüssig an. Man kann da zwar mal spielen, aber wenn du da irgendwie in Übungsmodus gehst oder so, dann ist es mir einfach permanent in die Ohren geflogen. Vielleicht muss ich auch einfach nochmal meine Rechner ein bisschen mehr rebooten, aber ich hab das Gefühl, dass die aktuelle Version, die so im Store liegt, zu viele Ressourcen frisst. Zu viel Rahmen, zu viel irgendwas. Und das ist alles noch nicht so befriedigend. Obwohl ich das Spiel an sich gerade jetzt auf dem iPhone für eine coole Sache halte. Ich mag auch so Games, die man entspannt spielen kann, wo man nicht so eine Zeithetze hat.
Was ich mal positiv erwähnen möchte, es sind zwei iPhone-Programme, die im Wesentlichen dasselbe machen. Ich hab sie beide mal ausprobiert. Das eine heißt Boxcar, das andere heißt Tweetpush.
Hatten wir das nicht schon hier, diese ganze Pusherei?
Hatten wir das schon?
Mit Twitter?
Gab's das letztes Mal schon?
Boxcar, bin ich mir jetzt grad nicht so sicher.
Ich hab mal gefragt, was es so für Alternativen gibt. Wobei ich sag, ich bin wieder zu Twitterific zurück. Dieses Tweety irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, dass ich immer hin und her schalten musste, fand ich blöd. Ist doch egal jetzt wo.
Nee, Moment mal. Also Boxcar und Tweetpush sind beides Programme, die einem Tweets per Notification zukommen lassen. Also DMs und Mansions. Bei Boxcar ist es so, du bezahlst einmal 80 Cent. Und hast es dann bei Tweetpush, die wollen 80 Cent im Monat sehen. Funktionieren tun sie beide. Tweetpush hat in meinen Augen den etwas schöneren Sound. Aber dass man da nicht einfach eine Sounddatei hochladen kann, die man dann hört, oder macht wie Klingelton-Einstellungen, das finde ich echt noch, das sollten sie da mal ein bisschen was für machen. Und die haben beide die Eigenschaft, sie wollen gar keine vollwertigen Clients sein, sondern wenn eine Notification kommt und man sagt Anzeigen, dann haben beide die Möglichkeit, oder beide sind in erster Linie darauf ausgelegt, dann den Twitter-Client deiner Wahl zu starten, also zum Beispiel Tweety oder Twitter-Form.
Ja, also ich hoffe ja immer noch, und denke auch immer noch, dass Twitter selber mit Push kommen wird.
Mal sehen.
Was sie jetzt einfach startetmäßig anbieten. Ich meine, wenn sie sich schon so eine Mühe geben, SMS zu unterstützen. Ja, was ja auch ein bremdes Netzwerk ist in den USA nicht.
Nee, da sind sie auch in Europa noch heftig dabei. Also jetzt haben sie, glaube ich, in England haben sie jetzt den zweiten, mit dem sie es... Den zweiten was? Neben Vodafone glaube ich jetzt auch noch bei O2, dass man kostenlos twittern kann per SMS. Also ich glaube, die sind heftig am Verhandeln, zumindest erstmal in englischsprachigen Ländern, dass da auch das SMS auch weiterhin gehen wird. Das ist eine wichtige Funktion.
Ich meine, wenn sie sich mit SMS so viel Mühe geben, dann können sie auch genauso gut einen Push-Service einführen für das iPhone. Ich meine, das ist definitiv lukrativ. Ich denke mal, dass keine andere mobile Plattform so viele Tweets erzeugt wie das iPhone. Das sieht man ja auch schon allein an einer schieren Zahl, an Twitter-Kleinen. Sie haben den keinen Überblick mehr.
Das Twitter ist so ein bisschen wie RSS-Feeds. Die gab es auf Windows am Anfang auch fast gar nicht, oder? So Programme dafür und so. Das heißt, die ganzen Web 2.0, hyper neuen, gehyped Features und so sind immer alle auf dem Mac.
Kann man so sehen, ja. Ich denke, ohne da jetzt der Windows-Welt zu sehr Schaden zuzufügen mit dem Statement, das ist so.
Vielleicht noch mal ein RSS-Reader. Ich war ja eigentlich sehr am Mac der RSS-Reader, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind. NetNews war er. Den habe ich aber schon vor einer ganzen Weile sein lassen, weil ich wollte.
Der ist ja aber umsonst, ne?
Der ist umsonst, genau. Ich habe ihn damals gekauft, als er noch Geld gekostet hat.
Die haben erst Geld haben wollen, und dann haben sie ihn auf kostenlos umgestellt?
Er ist gekauft worden. Er hatte vorher sein Geschäftsmodell, eine Software zu entwickeln.
Jetzt ist sein Geschäftsmodell, diese Software weiter zu entwickeln und sie kostenlos bereitzustellen, weil der damit hinterliegende Dienst verkauft wird. Wie heißt die Bude?
Aber auf jeden Fall so ein RSS.
Gilt es auch für die Desktop-Version? Ach so, die war immer umsonst, oder?
Nein, die Desktop-Version war die, die Geld gekostet hat. Gar nicht mal wenig, 20 Dollar oder 30 oder so. Und dann bin ich irgendwann auf einen Google-Reader umgestiegen, weil...
Newscater heißt es.
Newscater. Weil ich was haben wollte, was vernünftig synchronisiert.
Was natürlich ganz witzig ist, weil es ja gar keine API gibt dafür.
Doch, für einen Google-Reader gibt es offensichtlich eine API.
Ja, es gibt eine API, aber sie ist nicht dokumentiert.
Sie ist nicht dokumentiert? Also dafür gibt es aber unglaublich viele Clients auf einem iPhone.
Ja, sie ist wohl bekannt irgendwie.
Und jetzt habe ich mir mal den neuen RSS-Reader geleistet. Der FIWA heißt der. FIWA.
Was denn jetzt auf Mac?
Der ist webbasiert. Ach. Das heißt, man installiert ihn auf seiner eigenen Domain, man lädt ihn runter, man kriegt den Code geliefert. Ist so was, der hat den Code.
In the morning.
Ich finde, genau. Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Du guckst so lasziv. Und der ist webbasiert, ist von dem Typen, der vielleicht kennt, dass jemand das Statistiktool Mint geschrieben hat, was so ein ganz niedliches Tool ist, was leider nach hinten hin nicht so richtig gut funktioniert. Und der hat jetzt einen highly polished RSS-Reader geschrieben. Und Fieber, die Bezeichnung kommt daher, dass er eine Hot-Funktion eingebaut hat, nämlich wenn man sehr viele Feeds abonniert hat, verliert man ja gern mal den Überblick darüber. Und darum hat er so eine Funktion drin, dass er einem in Grad Celsius anzeigt, wie heiß ein Thema ist sozusagen. Also wenn jetzt viele Leute auf ein bestimmtes Thema verlinken.
Und wie fasst er das zusammen?
Das ist hier oben das Thema. Da ist die Überschrift ziemlich schaser gewählt, weil er announced ist. Da geht es um die BlackBerry Desktop Software, auf die jetzt viele gerade hinweisen. Und hier unten geht es dann um das Thema, das wir auch schon hatten, dass RIM und Apple 3% des Marktes haben, aber nur 35% der Profite. Kann man hier einstellen, über welchen Zeitraum das geht. Also zum Beispiel, das war jetzt für die letzten drei Tage, weil ich übers Wochenende weg war und keine Zeit hatte, irgendwas zu lesen. Unter normalen Umständen würde ich mir wahrscheinlich das Thema von heute zusammensuchen. Und da ist das Thema in erster Linie, dass es einen neuen iPod Touch mit Kamera vermutlich geben wird. Dann ist noch ganz wichtig der Selbstmord von dem Menschen, der offensichtlich iPhones geleakt hat aus der Fabrik und jetzt Selbstmord begangen hat.
Wie heißt das bei Spiegel Online?
Top-Meldung?
Nee, diese Rubrik, nicht Boulevard, sondern...
Was meinst du jetzt damit?
Na, die Boulevard-Abteilung beim Spiegel.
Keine Ahnung, wie die heißt.
Na, mal gucken. Panorama.
Panorama, okay.
Panorama-Tim.
Aber hier nochmal zu dem iPhone, was auch immer, der Typ, der sich da aus dem Fenster gestürzt hat. Das war ja nicht irgendein iPhone, das war ja höchstwahrscheinlich ein 4G-Prototyp.
Ich dachte vom 3GS.
Das wird dann 3GSX.
Da stand, also sind natürlich alles unbestätigte Rumors, weil wir werden es ja auch nie rausfinden, aber da stand 4G, also das nächste. Und wenn so ein Prototyp verschwindet, natürlich stürzt man sich dann aus dem Fenster. Du kriegst doch nie wieder einen Job, wenn du ein Apple-Prototyp verlierst, oder? Du bist doch durch auf dieser Welt.
Ich weiß gar nicht vorstellen, was für Zwingen die da ausgesetzt sind.
Ich hab's noch nicht gelesen.
Ist die Corona jetzt eigentlich gegessen?
Ja. Nee, hier hab ich noch ein Stück.
Hier, hau rein.
Das war meins, aber gib ich dir.
Der letzte Berg.
Der letzte Gipfel. Der Gipfel. Nächstes Mal gibt's Pizza? Ich hab's noch nicht.
Gedanken noch mal unseren Spendern. Genau. Das letzte Stück Schokolade. Ich weiß, es gibt auch noch das Angebot für Pizza, aber wir sind immer eigentlich alle schon so ein bisschen satt, wenn wir hierherkommen, oder?
Das ist eigentlich sehr clever, uns was essen zu sponsoren, weil je dicker wir werden, desto weniger attraktiv wirken wir auf unsere Umwelt und desto mehr Zeit haben wir uns auf Marktthemen zu konzentrieren.
So, was war jetzt gerade das Thema? Jetzt hab ich den Faden verloren.
Der Mensch, der aus dem Fenster gesprungen ist.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das war fertig. Okay, das war fertig.
Ich will noch kurz was für Snow Lab hat erzählen. Nur ganz kurz, damit wir was hinter uns haben.
Das ist übrigens ein tolles Geschäft.
Wie heißt nochmal das Programm mit den Flugzeugen?
Flight Control Case.
Ich hab eine ganz hübsche Idee für ein Geschäftsmodell. Wir machen zwei Versionen des Podcasts. Und eine ist gesexelt, die ist kostenlos. Deine ist in Hochdeutsch, die kostet dann.
Wer macht die in Hochdeutsch?
Vielleicht gibt es ja demnächst Leute, die dann in ihrem Landesdialekt die Podcasts nachsprechen.
Sollen sie einchecken.
Kürbste Mobile Max in Schwäbisch und Mobile Max in Sächsisch.
Und zwar habe ich ja berichtet mit dem PowerPC-Code und so, dass das irgendwie alles noch drin ist und eigentlich gehen müsste und so weiter. Habe ich natürlich ein bisschen weiter beobachtet.
Und Apple macht ja jetzt unüblicherweise, da habe ich ein interessantes Argument gehört, ne?
Und du sagst, der Max quatscht immer dazwischen. Ist doch unglaublich. Lass mich kurz ein erzählen und dann können wir gleich über. Also mit dem PowerPC-Code, dass er irgendwie noch mal noch drin ist und dass es eigentlich gehen müsste. Und da habe ich das ein bisschen beobachtet. Hatte ich ja alles schon erzählt. Shit. Und da die ja jetzt ja hier diese Software-Updates rausbringen, das heißt, die bringen keine neuen Images mehr raus, die man als Developer runterlädt, sondern das gibt es jetzt als Software-Update, was ziemlich praktisch ist, besonders dann, wenn man diese Images eigentlich gar nicht kriegt, von Apple, so wie ich nämlich. Deswegen kann ich ja darüber erzählen, weil ich keine NDA breche, das ist voll toll. Jedenfalls da drin habe ich mal geguckt und dieser PowerPC-Code, der verschwindet langsam. Also sie fangen jetzt langsam an, die Binaries durch normale zu ersetzen, die nur noch Intel-Code drin haben. Also nicht alles, es ist nicht so gleich auf einmal, aber so in bin und in userbin und so, wenn man mal da durchguckt, da sind manche noch mit Universal, also die alten natürlich und alle neuen habe ich geguckt, so vom Datum, die nämlich von dem Update sind, die haben ein neues Datum, die haben schon alle keinen Power-PC-Code mehr. Das heißt, es wird jetzt gerade ausgedünnt. Dann kann man mal davon ausgehen, dass zum Release alles weg ist, weil da macht es ja auch keinen Sinn mehr, weil wenn ein Kommando es schon nicht mehr hat, würde es ja nicht mehr gehen, also kannst du auch bei allen verschwinden. Das sind die News zu Snow Leopard. Und dass halt die Updates als Software-Update kommen, was wirklich bisher noch nicht so gewesen ist.
Ist denn eigentlich für...
Wie sagen die immer so?
Ist eigentlich für Rosetta irgendeine Power-PC-Basis erforderlich, oder ist das Ding wirklich eine reine...
Was meinst du mit Power-PC-Basis?
Na ja...
Rosetta ist ja der Power-PC-Emulator auf Intel.
Genau, bzw. ein Translator, der dann den Code on the fly in Intel-Code übersetzt und danach eben so direkt laufen lässt. Und ich glaube zwar gerade nicht, komme aber gerade so ein bisschen ins Grübeln, ob es irgendwie, wenn Power-PC-Code ausgeführt wird, also von Rosetta sozusagen lauffähig gemacht wird, ob dann irgendwelche Libraries auch noch quasi mit Power-PC-Entry Points oder so...
Oh Gott, gute Frage...
.verfügbar sein müssen wegen Calling Convention-Register, Schnickis und Gedöns.
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht so richtig. Da müsste man mal ein bisschen in sich gehen und ein bisschen drüber nachdenken.
Das kann aber eigentlich nicht sein. Ich glaub's nicht. Weil wenn so ein Power-PC-Programm kommt und auch seine eigenen Libs mitbringt, dann muss das Rosetta das ja auch können, weil die Libs hasst er dann als Intel auch nicht. Die liest er nur als Power-PC dabei. Und wenn es mit denen geht, die da mitgeliefert werden, dann muss es auch mit denen gehen, die da auf deinem Rechner sind.
Na gut, es geht ja eher so um Call von Frameworks von sozusagen Apple-seitig. Also wenn dann eben das Programm die Frameworks callt, in der Erwartung, es sei halt Power-PC oder es ist halt selber Power-PC, dass dann auch Power-PC-Code aufgerufen wird, dann muss ja dann im Prinzip Translation machen in den Intel-WR. Aber wenn sie eh den Code in Intel übersetzen, dann ist es ja wahrscheinlich an der Stelle auch mit Registern alles neu ausgelegt und irgendwie Byte-Order und der ganze Scheiß. Muss dann ja auch polyxidisch sein, sonst würde es ja nicht funktionieren. Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass es dafür geht. Also wenn es jetzt verschwindet, dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch bald vorbei.
Mit Rosetta?
Mit Power-PC. In Schneelo. Kann gut sein, dass sie die Entscheidung, es wirklich fallen zu lassen, recht spät gefällt haben. Und dass sie jetzt einfach sagen, wir machen das, dass sie sich das noch offen gelassen haben bis zum letzten Moment.
Wollen wir mal kurz durchatmen? Ein kleinen Wechsel machen.
Ein kleinen Wechsel machen?
Du wolltest aufs Thema Palme Pré erzählen, stimmt's?
Ich wollte jetzt über Amazon erzählen.
Oh, die digitale Bücherverbrennung.
Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein?
Ihr macht das mal und ich geh mal für kleine Podcaster.
Bücher.
Das geht Bücher löschen.
Ich leg das hier mal ein bisschen weiter nach da drüben, damit es nicht das Mikro, damit das nicht irgendwie reinfliegt. Ja, Amazon hat, die haben ja diesen tollen Amazon-Kindl und dieses digitale, diesen E-Book-Reader, der ein kleines Modem eingebaut hat und mit dem Amazon ganz einfach, über dieses Whispernet Bücher auf das Gerät kopieren kann und was jedem schon ewig lange bewusst war, aber was ich eher für eine theoretische Gefahr hielt, Amazon kann darüber auch Bücher wieder löschen.
Was ist jetzt passiert?
Das haben sie jetzt gemacht.
Warum ist das passiert?
Ausgerechnet, muss man natürlich mal zu sagen, bei den Büchern 1984 und Animal Farm.
Von George Orville.
Von George Orville. Ruhe ist, wer diese Bücher nicht kennt. Genau, um die Situationen kennen, indem irgendjemand die Information die ganze Zeit kontrolliert.
Besser wäre noch gewesen, in so einem Nazi-Widerstandsbuch, irgendwie die weiße Rose.
Wie heißt es, Farmheit 451? Das wäre eigentlich der Klassiker gewesen.
Aber Orville ist auch schon super.
Orville ist auch schon super. Und zwar, weil sie wohl die Rechte nicht dran hatten. Also, irgendjemand hat dieses Buch reingestellt. In den Amazon Bücher Store. Und jetzt hat sich der Verlag gemeldet, der eigentlich die Rechte an dem Buch hat. Und hat gesagt, nee, nee, gib das mal wieder zurück.
Ist aber gekauft worden.
Das heißt, durfte aber nicht verkauft werden. Und deswegen wird es den Leuten von dem Kindle gelöscht. Und die Kohle wird aber rückerstattet.
Die Kohle wird rückerstattet. Also ich meine, das wäre jetzt ja wirklich...
Tut mir leid, sie haben leider etwas gekauft, was wir nicht verkaufen durften.
Ja, aber ich finde es erst... Also ich finde das schon so... Man kauft sich legal ein Buch. Also ich meine, dass Amazon nicht das Recht hat, dieses Buch zu verkaufen, ist mir als Kunde ja eigentlich wurscht. Ich kaufe legal ein fucking Buch.
Du kaufst ja kein Buch, sondern du kaufst ja ein Buchleserecht.
Genau das ist es. Diesen Eindruck probieren sie ja zu vermeiden, aber genau das ist es im Endeffekt. Und was ich für den großen Nachteil an dieser Technologie halte, ich meine, wo wird das noch hinführen? Das wird dazu hinführen, dass in Zukunft Bücher veröffentlicht werden. Also lass das mal so eine unauthorisierte Biografie von irgendjemand sein. Und dann drückt der vor Gericht durch, dass da aber nicht drin stehen darf, dass der mit 15 Mal Drogen genommen hat. Und dann wird sich wahrscheinlich in Zukunft auch so was ergeben, dass sich ein Buch einfach auf magische Art und Weise verändert, wenn der Gerichtsprozess entsprechend ausgeht. Und das heißt, wir werden unsere Bücher, wenn wir solche E-Book-Reader kaufen, werden sich unsere Bücher unter unserem Arsch weg hin verändern. Oder entfernen oder löschen oder wie auch immer.
So wie Wikipedia.
So wie die Wikipedia.
Die ändert sich ja auch unter unserem Arsch.
Ja, aber da gibt es wenigstens noch theoretisch so etwas wie eine Historie. Und ich bin mir der Tatsache bewusst, wohingegen, wenn ich so einen E-Book-Reader habe, dann rechne ich eigentlich damit, dass alles, was da einmal drauf ist, da gefälligst auch drauf bleibt.
Das stimmt.
Und mit anderen Worten, man sollte einen E-Book-Reader kaufen, wo man sich sicher sein kann, dass man da die volle Kontrolle über den Content hat. Weil ansonsten kann man sich nicht sicher sein, dass er sich nicht auf magische Art und Weise plötzlich ändert, wenn ein Buchverlag glaubt, die Rechte irgendwo anhalten zu müssen. Und man muss auch mal sagen, Amazon, ihr seid sowas von bekloppt. Ihr macht aus der theoretisch existierenden Angst, die nur relativ schwer zu vermittelbar ist, macht ihr einen praktischen Fall. Und dann ausgerechnet bei 1984.
Konnten sie, ich meine, in dem Moment konnten sie es nicht verhindern, ne? Denke ich mal. Ich meine, es war natürlich für sie dramatisch, dass es ausgerechnet das ist. Aber ich meine, was sollten sie dann tun, wenn sie das eh schon unter diesen Bedingungen durchgeführt haben?
Also zum einen wäre es vielleicht von vornherein eine ganz gute Idee gewesen, dieses Feature einfach gar nicht einzubauen.
Ja gut, aber wahrscheinlich haben sie viele diese Rechte überhaupt erst bekommen unter dieser Maßgabe.
Ja, ich meine, ich verstehe das Dilemma, in dem sie sind.
Ich will sie ja gar nicht verteidigen, aber ich denke mal, das ist eben auch wie bei der Musik, wie bei Apple und der Musikindustrie. Also selbst wenn Apple gewollt hätte, so konnten sie halt nicht.
Ja, aber Apple konnte so einen Gau bisher verhindern. Also dass dieses, dass wirklich irgendwie jemand sein Repertoire rausgenommen hat und das alles, was ich mir gekauft habe. Und ich glaube nicht, dass die Musikindustrie sich wesentlich unzickiger anstellt als die Verlagsbranche.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Meinst du, sie sind weniger zickig? Meinst du, sie waren am Anfang weniger zickig als die Buchverlage?
Am Anfang? Wer jetzt? Die Musikindustrie? Ob die am Anfang weniger, an welchem Anfang?
Als der Apple iTunes Store kam und als die ersten, als sie mitgekriegt haben, Moment mal, das läuft gut.
Ich meine, die Verlage derzeit irgendwie durchdrehen mit Google Books und tralala.
So dreht die Musikindustrie seit Jahren durch. Ich glaube, da hat Apple einfach Hintergrund gut verhandelt und besser. Hey, haltet mal die Schnauze und tut auch nicht weh, wenn wir euch jetzt gleich töten.
Sie hatten den Vorteil, ein kleiner Player zu sein. Ich meine, Apple ist ja mit iTunes aufgetreten und hat gesagt, komm, lasst uns auf uns ein, wir sind nur 3% des Marktes und ihr habt sowieso alle Windows und wisst ja gar nicht, was das ist. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ach ja, da experimentieren wir mal. So. Und das wars. Aber Amazon ist natürlich von vornherein schon der Platzhirsch. Und da gibt es ein ganz anderes Bedrohungspotenzial. Und ich denke mal, dass die Verlage, also ich weiß, dass die Verlage, also in Deutschland zum Beispiel, eine riesen Schiss vor Amazon.
Natürlich. Mehr vor Amazon.
Amazon diktiert ihnen halt die Preise, Google diktiert ihnen keine Preise.
In Deutschland haben wir noch die Buchpreisbindung. Das heißt, da diktiert Amazon noch nicht so richtig viel. Aber in Amerika diktieren die die Preise. Und die werden auch auf diesem Kindle gerät, während die natürlich, wird das ja schon mal werden zu sein.
Ja, Buchpreisbindung bezieht sich ja aber auch nur auf den Endpreis, nicht auf den Händlerpreis. Das heißt, du musst das am Ende für den Preis...
Na, aber dadurch hat dadurch...
Oder ist der Einkaufspreis dadurch auch festgelegt?
Das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt.
Der Preis, den Amazon bezahlt, den verhandelt die Mainzer. Dass die schön billig einkaufen.
Aber das, was übers Internet vertrieben wird an Büchern, ist in Deutschland nach wie vor relativ gering. Der Einzelbuchhandel ist noch deutlich wichtiger als in Amerika, weil eben dieser Preisvorteil von Amazon einfach schlechthin ergreifend fehlt. Und weil die diesen Vorteil nicht ausspielen können. Und in Amerika konnten sie das und haben dementsprechend...
Trotzdem haben sie irgendwie Schiss. Und das ist in den USA nicht anders. Und von daher denke ich mal, wenn die Verlage da schon auch drauf gedrungen haben, dass so eine Möglichkeit besteht. Das fällt natürlich jetzt trotzdem alles auf Amazon zurück. Ich bin mir sowieso nicht so sicher, ob dieser E-Book-Markt noch mal wirklich kommt. Also ich glaub da noch nicht. Also ich glaub weder das eine noch das andere so richtig. Ich bin mir einfach nur unsicher. Aber ich hab echt meine Zweifel, dass diese E-Book-Lesegeräte als solche einen durchschlagenden Erfolg darstellen werden irgendwann. Ich weiß nicht, ich will...
War mit den MP3-Playern am Anfang auch erstmal komisch jahrelang? Weil die gab's ja schon, weil dann der iPod kam.
Ja, aber Musikabspielgeräte, elektronische gab's schon immer.
Ja, stimmt.
Also Walkman und irgendwie tragbares Kassettenradio, das ist schon seit 30, 40 Jahren.
Ja, so ein MP3-Player war dann schon noch ein bisschen komplett anders als ein Walkman. Vielleicht fehlt ja auf dem...
Ja, aber es war schon eine Evolution.
Vielleicht fehlt ja auf diesem Markt, vielleicht sind diese ganzen Standard-LCD-Geräte, das ist halt noch nicht die Evolution oder Revolution. Sondern man muss vielleicht wirklich durchsichtig, also durch dieses Papier kommen.
Also ich muss ja ehrlich gestehen, bei mir ist gar nicht mehr der Fall, dass das Buch irgendwas ablösen muss, also dass es das Buch ablösen muss, weil ich lese im Augenblick überhaupt gar keine Bücher. Wenn mir irgendjemand ein vernünftiges Lesegerät für mein iPhone geben würde, auf dem ich Lust habe, lange Inhalte zu lesen, dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich tun.
Es gibt ja schon einiges zu lesen. Es gibt ja auch Manuals, es gibt Tageszeitungen und so. Also ich lese schon auch Papier.
Mach ich wirklich quasi null.
Aber wenn ich wirklich so ein Manual hab, und ich will es wirklich lesen, dann druck ich mir das aus.
Du bist so ein Internet-Ausdrucker.
Ich bin so ein Internet-Ausdrucker.
Nee, ich hab keinen Drucker mehr.
Das funktioniert besser, das Papier. Da kann ich mehrere Seiten gleichzeitig sehen. Zum Beispiel, das ist etwas, was auch auf so einem E-Book nicht geht.
Ja, aber dafür hab ich ein paar Vorteile. Ich kann zum Beispiel suchen. Suchen kann ich auch auf meinem Computer.
Dafür brauch ich kein E-Book.
Nee, ein E-Book nicht, aber gegenüber dem ausgedruckten oder gegenüber dem klassischen Buch hat es den Vorteil, dass ich eine Folge suchen muss.
Ja klar, aber ich red jetzt wirklich so über dieses Inn unserer heutigen Zeit. Die Leute haben einfach ein Laptop und da willst du eigentlich deine Sachen haben. Und da, wenn ich so ein E-Book kaufe, dann will ich das durchsuchbar auf meinem Mac haben. Dann will ich, dass da das Spotlight greift und dass wenn ich nach irgendwas suche, dass ich dieses Buch gefunden will.
Das muss auf jeden Fall mit rein.
Das suche ich nicht auf so einem dedizierten Teil. So ein dediziertes Teil ist dann wirklich eben dedicated to presentation des unmittelbaren Contents. Aber das überzeugt mich einfach nicht mit diesem Display. Und so sehr diese E-Book Displays auch immer hochgejubelt werden, wie nah das Hit am Papier ist, es ist ein winziger Ausriss, es ist ein winziges Stück von einem möglichst großen Papier. Und ich finde einfach so eine dünne A4-Seite hat einfach was. Einfach schön zusammentackern, hat man was in der Hand, kann man umblättern.
Faschelt so schön.
Ja, kannst du einen Stift nehmen, kannst du was drauf markieren, das ist auf diesen komischen E-Book dann auch nicht so machbar. Mal eben was einkreisen und so. Klar, theoretisch geht das auch, aber dann hast du ja so digitale Marken drauf. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich da auch zu konservativ, aber ich bin skeptisch, was E-Books betrifft.
Ja, ich finde, das gibt es durchaus auch begründet, aber ich glaube, wenn wir erstmal die E-Book wieder haben im größeren Umfang, dann wird es so eine Revolution an freier, also es wird die Literatur verändern wie wahrscheinlich seit langem nichts mehr.
Die Literatur?
Ja. Ich glaube, das Buch an sich wird sich ändern.
Das Buch an sich wird sich ändern?
Genau. Also ich meine, so bei Musikverkauf ist es ja so, dass früher war ja das Album das Medium, in dem gehandelt worden ist. Das ist mittlerweile ja eher die Single. Und unter anderem auch dadurch, durch den Einzelverkauf… Ich hab jetzt natürlich keine… Ich hab jetzt keine konkrete Zahlen da.
Du hast zwar schon immer als Single Charts.
Bei dem Buch kann man demnächst die Seiten auch einzeln kaufen?
Nee, man wird nicht die Seiten einzeln kaufen müssen, aber…
Es wird dahin gehen, dass man zum Beispiel… Manche Seiten kannst du nur im kompletten Buch kaufen.
Nee, ich glaube zum Beispiel, das ist eine einzelne Kurz… Also im Augenblick hat man doch… Man erwartet ja, wenn man so ein Buch kauft, auch, dass man ein paar Kilo Papier kriegt dafür. Also man bezahlt ja auch durchaus nach Masse. Und wir wissen, dass bei jedem Buch so und so viele… Oder bei den meisten Büchern so und so viele Seiten nur existieren, um auf eine gewisse Dicke des Buches zu kommen. Da musste sich der Autor nochmal irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen, damit er auf Masse kommt.
Ja, jetzt bei Internet for Dummies meinst du…
Sachbücher zum Beispiel, ja klar.
Aber doch jetzt nicht Belletristik und…
Der Roman zum Beispiel, der Roman ist eigentlich bei Belletristik. Kurzgeschichten kannst du mit kurzgeschichten…
Du meinst fünf oder sechs Kapitel im Roman sind nur, damit das dick wird?
Das glaube ich. Ich weiß nicht, ob es fünf oder sechs Kapitel sind, aber zum Beispiel…
Nicht die Kapitel, sondern die sind halt aufgedunsen.
Ich glaube, die Diskussion dürftest du mit keinem Literaturwissenschaftler oder sowas führen.
Ach, das kann man sehr gut…
Stell dir vor, Reich Raditzky würde jetzt beim Mobile-Max mit auftreten. Herr Winde! Wie sind die? Was die da überhaupt sagen?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht zu halten.
Doch, das ist zu halten. Du hast mit kurzgeschichten keine Chance im Netz, im Buchmarkt. Es gibt keine Kurzgeschichtensammlung zu kaufen. Jedenfalls nicht, wenn du ein Newcomer bist. Weil will niemand. Die Leute wollen Romane. Die wollen dicke Bücher haben, wo sie an einer Geschichte lange lesen. Und ich glaube, das wird sich selbstverständlich ändern in dem Moment, in dem man mal sagen kann, hier kauf ich mal für 20 Cent oder für einen Euro oder sowas.
Die Leute wollen. Also das ist mir so ein bisschen zu allgemein. Ich könnte gleich ein Gegenbeispiel aufführen. Was verkauft sich wie Sau im Lesemarkt? Arztromane, Groschenhefte, das geht weg wie warme Semmel. Das geht schon seit Ewigkeiten und das ist nicht dick. Und das ist nicht schwer, sondern das ist explizit dünn. Und das ist irgendwie immer wieder neu und immer wieder das Gleiche.
Ja, aber wir sehen uns in Stephen King, so eine dicke Bücher, wo die Leute sich die Handgelenke brechen.
Ja, es gibt alles. Aber ich meine, ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht, woher du dieses, das E-Book oder das Internet wird die Literatur ändern.
Also ich kann explizit jemanden.
Ich sehe auch nicht, dass die Musik geändert wurde. Also was ist denn neu an der Musik? Hat sich irgendwas getan, was ich nicht mitbefügt? Was denn?
Länger.
Was ist länger? Die CDs sind immer noch genauso lang wie sonst auch.
Aber vorher gab es Schallplatte, 40 Minuten, zack. Was?
Na und? Da gab es Doppelschallplatte. Habe ich genug von gehabt? Also ich sehe einfach keine qualitative Änderungen im Musikmarkt, was jetzt das Produkt an sich betrifft. Es gibt Hits und es gibt die anderen Sachen, es gibt Alben und es gibt irgendwie Sachen, die sich in kleinen Compilations verkaufen, es gibt irgendwie Singles, es gibt EPs, es gibt irgendwie all diesen ganzen Klimpim.
Also zum Beispiel, ja.
Und dann hat der ganze digitale Distributionsmarkt gar nichts verändert. Das ist ja auch das, was Apple gesagt hat. Ja, alle hatten Angst, oh Gott, irgendwann kauft uns keiner mehr die Alben ab, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, die Zahlen, die sie veröffentlicht haben, aber das hat sich einfach nicht bestätigt. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich das im Buchmarkt groß ändern wird, nur weil jetzt etwas digital da ist. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sich neue Formate etablieren, die derzeit keine Abnehmer finden, weil sie in den Stückzahlen, die zu erwarten sind, so unökonomisch sind, als Print ausgeliefert werden. Okay, gerne, aber Revolution irgendwie?
Nee, nicht nur das, sondern ich glaube zum Beispiel, dass es beim Musik und das ist, da ist die Digitalisierung allein, ist da glaube ich, der Vertrieb über das Internet allein, ist da noch nicht so ausschlaggebend, sondern da muss auch das Marketing sich ändern, da muss sich die ganze Infrastruktur ändern. Aber ich glaube auch, dass im Rahmen der Notwendigkeit gegen Piraterie fort, also dass sie Mittel finden wollen, was jetzt über die böse Keule hinaus und den Anwalt sofort, was der Piraterie ein bisschen entgegenwirkt und auch weil es die Möglichkeit plötzlich gibt, dass da zum Beispiel, dass es üblich werden wird, nicht ein Album am Stück zu veröffentlichen, sondern dass Bands zum Beispiel Jahresabbrüche verkaufen werden. Dass du sagst, ich kauf alles, was in dem Jahr kommt für eine Band.
Jetzt bist du wieder bei Musik. Genau. Und das Subscription-Modell, wo?
Nein, kein Subscription-Modell, sondern einfach, ich bezahle jetzt...
Jahresabbruch hast du gesagt, das ist ein Subscription-Modell.
Jedes Musikstück, was in dem Jahr kommt, habe ich automatisch für immer. Das soll kein Subscription-Modell sein?
Das ist nicht ein Subscription-Modell. Aber für ein Jahr ein Abo.
Aber man darf die Musik nach dem Jahr nichts behalten.
Worauf willst du jetzt hinaus? Wir waren bei E-Books und du warst der Meinung, irgendwas würde sich ändern. Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass sich überhaupt irgendetwas wirklich nennenswert ändert. Ich sehe noch nicht mal, dass dieser E-Book-Markt als solcher wirklich kommt. Amazon hat mit seinen Kindern irgendwelche Verkaufszahlen postuliert, von denen kein Mensch weiß, ob die stimmen. Sie haben auch mal gesagt, dass, glaube ich, von allen Büchern, die sie auch elektronisch anbieten, 30% aller Verkäufe elektronisch sind. Das klingt nach einem enormen Erfolg. Ich glaube es irgendwie aber trotzdem nicht. Also ich glaube einfach nicht, dass diese Leute mit so einem Gerät zuhause sitzen und Bücher lesen. Also ich glaube sicher, dass das einige tun. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das für die Leute, die wirklich Buchleser sind, dass das so attraktiv ist. Ich finde, diese Geräte sind einfach nicht gut.
Ich sage nicht, dass es zwangsläufig so ein E-Book-Reader wie das Kindl-Gerät ist. Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das iPhone hat eine gute Chance.
Das denke ich auch. Dazu muss es auch noch größer werden.
Und wenn man bedenkt, wie sich meine Leseverhalten schon durch das iPhone geändert haben, nämlich ich lese keine Bücher mehr, ich lese Tweets. Und jetzt kann man auf der einen Seite sagen...
Das ist ja mein Ersatz.
Du liest Tweets. Ich lese zum Beispiel Tweets, ich lese Blogartikel, mein gesamtes Leseverhalten ist mittlerweile auf online Medien angelegt.
Gibt es schon so Services, wo man sich Bücher als Tweets schicken lassen kann? Bücher als Tweets?
Die Bibel, glaube ich.
Die Bibel haben sie getwittert.
Du followst Herr der Ringe und dann kommt es immer so, alle 10 Sekunden so ein Satz.
Das ist bestimmt wieder böses Copyright violation.
Naja, ich glaube, es hat mein Leseverhalten schon geändert, es hat auch dein Leseverhalten schon geändert. Warum soll da nicht ein Lesegerät kommen, was diesem Leseverhalten entspricht?
Was hat mein Lesegerät, mein Leseverhalten geändert?
Wie viel Prozent von dem, was du liest, liest du im Netz? Wie oft liest du tatsächlich noch Print?
Ich lese eigentlich einmal am Tag Zeitung.
Für wie lange?
So lange wie mein Frühstück dauert.
Und das hast du schon immer so gemacht und das wird sich niemals ändern?
Das weiß ich nicht. Nö, das war mal so, mal so. Derzeit bin ich halt nicht, bin ich also unfall genug, mir auch wirklich eine Zeitung zu kaufen.
Also bei mir ist es jetzt einfach mal so meine Erfahrung. Ich hab war zum Beispiel früher ein leidenschaftlicher CT-Leser. Ich hab jedes Heft gekauft und hab's fast von A bis Z durchgelesen.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich würde ganz gerne mein Internet auf so einer Zeitung lesen. Also wenn ich morgens zum Frühstück, die sich über den Abend und die Nacht angestauten Twitter-Wolken und so weiter, wenn ich die irgendwie schön layoutet auf so einem A0-Faltblatt hätte, das fände ich geil.
Na ja, dann kannst du ja nicht hinterherklicken.
Ist egal. Dann klicke ich da nicht hinterher, sondern da informiere ich mich. Da kriege ich sozusagen schon den einmal durchgekaut.
Na ja, aber wie weit ist das von dem aktuellen E-Book-Reader weg?
Ja, so ein E-Book-Reader ist so eine kleine Funze. Das ist irgendwie so ein A5, ein A6-Blatt.
Du willst statt einer 5 einen A0 haben?
Ja, doppelseite auf den Tisch legen.
Und du möchtest es gerne falten können?
Mir geht es nicht so sehr ums Falten. Ich finde einfach, dass die Größe der Präsentation eine Menge ausmacht. Warum haben denn die Leute heute 30 Zoll-Bildschirme?
Na ja, wie viel Fantasie gehört dazu, dass in zwei, drei Jahren A0-Displays bei E-Ink absolut Stand der Dinge sein werden?
Das glaube ich halt einfach nicht, dass man sich wirklich so ein elektronisches Gerät im A0-Format auf den Tisch legt. Es ist einfach, was ist das für ein Aufwand? Also das ist irgendwie, vielleicht werde ich, ja, dieser Podcast wird in 50 Jahren ausgegraben werden und sie werden alle über mich lachen.
Das schöne an der Zeitung ist ja, die kann kaputtgehen, weil die interessiert dann eh keinen mehr. Dieses E-Book, also...
Ich kann jetzt nicht alle technischen Revolutionen hervorahnen. Derzeit sieht es einfach nicht danach aus, dass irgendwas entwickelt wird, was sich in einem vertretbaren Aufwand zu einem vertretbaren Preis produzieren lässt, was dann auch konkurrenzfähig ist mit dem, was wir heute als Papier kennen. Ich glaube schon, dass sich der Zeitschriftenmarkt und der Zeitungsmarkt nachhaltig ändern wird. Gar keine Diskussion, das tut er ja bereits auch. Überhaupt die ganze News-Medienwelt, das wird sich ändern. Das hat sich schon geändert und das wird sich auch noch weiterhin ändern. Bloß bei diesen nachhaltigen Produkten wie Musik und Büchern kann schon sein, die Darreichungsform wird sich vielleicht elektronifizieren. Aber diese Wahrnehmung über ein Gerät, ich hab einfach meine Zweifel. Bei Musik ist das was anderes, da sind die Dinger wunderbar. Beim Printen. Aber wir müssen es auch nicht weiter vertiefen, weil wir bewegen uns hier irgendwie im Kreis. Also wir lassen uns einfach mal da so stehen. Du bist schon der Meinung, dass so ein E-Book-Reader irgendwie funktionieren kann, aber wenn ich es richtig verstehe, gibt es auch noch nichts, was dir wirklich gefällt?
Sehe ich das richtig so, Max?
Oder gibt es... Wenn es was gäbe, was dir gefällt, dann hättest du es schon ein. Also gibt es nichts.
Also es gibt nichts, was mir aber auffällt, dass es bei mir nicht mehr die Notwendigkeit ist, da irgendwie mit Papier die Konkurrenz aufzunehmen, weil Papier lese ich auch nicht mehr. Ich lese keine gedruckten Sachen mehr. Und mein Konsum ist hier, ich habe hier ungefähr 500 Tabs offen, die...
Gibt es eigentlich einen Twitter-Klan, der auch drucken kann? Kann Twitty eigentlich drucken? Hab ich noch nie drüber nachgedacht.
Tweed-Ausdrucker.
Tatsache! Was printet ihr denn jetzt? Das bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Mach einen PDF draus. Krass!
Den printet tatsächlich ernsthaft das, was jetzt auf dem Bildschirm zu sehen ist. Das ist ja wohl wirklich ein Name. Der nimmt dann einfach sein Web-View und druckt den aus. Also ich bitte euch, da könnt ihr die Funktion auch gleich abschalten. Naja. Twitter-Ausdrucker. So, haben wir denn noch ein tragendes Thema. Was ist mit Pirate Bay? Dennis, hast du deine Hausaufgaben gemacht?
Nicht wirklich.
Also, die neuesten Leuchtigkeiten von heute. Kannst du mir mal diese Trecker-Geschichte mit diesen beiden offenen Treckern erzählen? Na, erst kam dieses openbittorrent.com raus. Und dann gab's, jetzt hab ich den Namen leider vergessen von der anderen Seite, eine in demselben Webdesign, im selben Wording noch mal ein anderes Announcement, dass hier ein freier Trecker kommt. Aber wirklich genau dieselbe Webseite in einer anderen Farbe.
Das Problem ist ja, dass zum Beispiel Mininova, die haben keinen eigenen Trecker. Die haben immer einfach nur Torrens verteilt. Und da war meistens der Trecker der von Pirate Bay. Wenn der natürlich jetzt wegfällt, haben die bei Mininova ein Problem. Weil die sind ja auf Trecker angewiesen. Auch wenn es natürlich noch ein paar andere gibt, aber der von Pirate Bay waren schon der größte.
Wer hat dasselbe Problem? Die brauchen auch einen Trecker.
Wer hat dasselbe Problem?
Pirate Bay braucht ja auch einen Trecker.
Wie die das lösen wollen, ist mir auch noch ein bisschen unklar. Ich hab ja damals schon gesagt, weil der Trecker kostet Geld, wenn die das trennen wollen, weiß ich auch nicht, was die sich da vorstellen. Das ist eben ein bisschen unklar. Aber diese wie Mininova und noch so ein paar andere Sites tun sich wohl zusammen und machen so ein Trecker-Netzwerk. Da wird gerade gebastelt, dass die untereinander dann auch über Tunnels eventuell gesynkt werden und so weiter, und die sich die Kosten wohl teilen oder irgendwie so. Ist noch nicht so ganz klar.
Aber gibt es denn schon irgendwelche Maßnahmen im BitTorrent-Protokoll, so eine Transferierbarkeit von Torrents auf andere Trecker?
Nee, aber da machen die einfach mit irgendwelchen Skripten, gehen über alle Torrents drüber, die die haben, schmeißen den Pilot bei raus, tragen einen neuen ein.
Achso, das heißt, man muss dann ein neues Torrent-File runterleihen?
Also es hebt eigentlich sowieso nie irgendein Torrent-File auf, du lädst es runter und dann hörst du ja auf damit. Also wenn du wirklich einen Torrent hast, was dich wirklich, was wichtig ist und du willst es die ganze Zeit ziehen, dann lädst du es halt neu runter oder änderst den Trecker selber. Der Trecker ist ja nicht Teil von dem Hash, der da mit bei ist, das heißt, es ändert nichts.
Der Hash bezieht sich nur auf den Inhalt, nicht darüber, wo es getrackt wird.
Genau, deswegen kann man den ändern.
Das heißt, man sucht quasi nur nach......einem Torrent mit dem selben Hash. Das heißt, man findet zwar dieselbe Datei, aber man findet unter Umständen ein Torrent, was auf andere Trecker verweist. Das hat in dem Moment natürlich auch Vorteile.
Genau, und man könnte auch zusätzlich welche eintragen, weil inzwischen gibt es ja auch Multitracker und so weiter und so fort.
Und was ist jetzt mit Pirate Bay selber?
So, Nadie haben mir irgendwie was erzählt, dass sie das jetzt auch mit, wie hieß es, mit Subscription-Modell irgendwie verkaufen wollen. Also, dass man sich da anmelden muss und einen Account braucht. Und dass man irgendwie...
Das ist doch eine Schnaps-Idee.
Ja, die haben auch irgendeinen Typen eingekauft, der vorher bei... Groxta oder so der Chef war? Irgendso ein Rossi oder Rosso oder sowas? Keine Ahnung, kennt sich wohl ein bisschen aus.
Groxta? Oh Gott, was war denn das nochmal?
Oder vertue ich mich jetzt? Sagt hier schon einer was anderes? Ich weiß nicht, oder Casa war es nicht, aber ich glaube, es war Groxta. Ich weiß auch nicht, was Groxta war. Keine Ahnung, so ein Peer-to-Peer-Zeugs nehme ich an. Ja, hier Groxta, Peer-to-Peer, Falltjering, 2001. Au, alte Scheiße. Egal. Jedenfalls wollen sie da irgendwie Geld verdienen. Ich weiß nicht, was sie genau vorhaben, aber die Leute sollen ihren Rechner zur Verfügung stellen. Also sie sollen irgendwie wohl auch mitziehen oder irgendwie so.
Oder betrecken.
Umso mehr sie das machen, umso weniger müssen sie bezahlen. Das wird dann irgendwie gut gerechnet. Also man kann wohl so viel mitmachen, dass man am Ende eigentlich gar nichts mehr bezahlt. Jetzt ist nur die Frage, wo soll denn diese Software kommen? Also ist das alles auch nur Vaporware? Und irgendwann mal vielleicht könnte es so sein, was muss man doch alles erstmal schreiben?
Ja, das ist diese Software, die von diesen Peerrealism Leuten geschrieben wird. Das ist doch das, wovon die da reden, von diesem Peer-to-Peer-Kram.
Das weiß ich halt eben noch nicht.
Ja, so richtig wissen tue ich das auch nicht, aber das war ja die Ankündigung, dass sie die Bude mitkaufen und dass die halt an einem Peer-to-Peer-Tracking arbeiten.
Verstehe.
Das ist ja meine These, die wollen eigentlich weg von diesem angreifbaren Trecker hin zu einem Modell, wo sich das verteilt aus Lastgründen und vielleicht eben auch aus gesetzlichen Gründen. Im Falle von Pirate Bay, wo sie ja jetzt alle so brav und ordentlich sind, träumen sie wahrscheinlich davon, eine Migration zu machen auf das neue Protokoll. Allerdings habe ich ja meine Zweifel, dass sie die Community mitnehmen, wenn es nicht sowas gibt wie Pirate Bay.
Na, ich sehe das auch so. Ich sehe das so, dass es genauso wird wie damals, wo irgendwie Napster gekauft wurde. Die dachten sich auch, sie kriegen eine Million von Usern und das wird voll toll. Und können da voll irgendwie Sachen machen und viel Geld verdienen. Aber Leute, die bei Pirate Bay einen Account haben, das sind keine Kunden. Das sind Leute, die einen Account haben, weil man da anders keine Kommentare schreiben kann. Das ist der einzige Grund. Und weil man anders keine, kann man Torrents auch ohne Account eintragen. Ich weiß das gar nicht. Ich mach ja die welche. Kann sein, dass man auch zum Torrent-Hochladen auch einen Account braucht. Denk mal schon. Und das ist der einzige Grund, warum man einen Account hat. Warum sollte man sonst einen Account haben? Und weil man sonst keine Pornos kriegt. So war's, glaube ich.
Wie? Man kriegt keine Pornos ohne Account?
Ich glaube, ohne Account kriegst du keine Pornos bei Pirate Bay gelistet.
Keine gelistet?
Ja, hast du schon mal Pornos gesehen? Bei Pirate Bay?
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie welche gesucht.
Na, die würden ja so mit auftauchen, egal was du suchst.
Weil die Suche so schlecht ist.
Das auch, ja. Und weil irgendwas matcht doch immer, also weißt schon.
Ja gut, mir ist jetzt...
Irgendwas matcht doch immer.
Mir ist jetzt so bewusst nichts in Erinnerung geblieben.
Ja, dann hast du da keinen Account, also kommen keine Pornos.
Also meinst du, ich muss mit meinem Account suchen und dann finde ich Pornos?
Sonst wären die halt nicht gelistet.
Verstehe.
Bumm.
Na ja, vielleicht machen sie ja jetzt... Vielleicht machen sie jetzt auf Pornos und sagen es bloß noch keinen. Das darf sein.
Was heute durchkam, ist, dass irgendwie ein Sprecher da von dieser Gaming oder wie heißt die? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Bude heißt. Und was GGF nennt sie die mal oder sowas? Dass sie gesagt haben, der Deal findet erst im August statt. Und dass, wenn bis dahin nicht klar ist, ob sie nun wirklich das ganze Asset oder das Ganze übernehmen können, was sie dann interessiert, also die User-Basis und so weiter, dass der Deal dann auch gar nicht stattfinden wird. Also ihr habt das Gefühl, die rudern schon wieder leicht zurück. Also da ist noch gar nicht ein trockenen Tüch an der Deal.
Nee, nee, ist er nicht, ist er nicht, ist er nicht. Das war ja auch klar.
Vor allem weil die Show und auch die Musikindustrie sagt, wenn da irgendein Geld fließt, dann wollen wir das. Weil ihr wurdet da verklagt und ihr müsst uns bezahlen. Wobei das noch gar nicht rechtskräftig ist und deswegen eigentlich auch nicht geht.
Wir müssen da noch mal nach Hack, glaube ich. Hack, hack. Im Chat gibt es Links auf Pirate Bay, da wo Porno kommt.
Ach so, weil der hier, man muss, anscheinend 500 ist die Kategorie für Porn und dann kommt auch Porn, aber so normalerweise, glaube ich, kommt der nicht. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Ach so, nicht in der Suche oder was? Ist ja Quatsch, wenn es da für eine Kategorie gibt. Also hier gibt es genug Porn. Also wenn das alles Porn ist.
Ja, aber der hat jetzt an der Ola einfach die 500 als Kategorie eingetragen, glaube ich. Die kriegst du normalerweise, wenn du da so rumkommst nicht. Und wer kann schon sowas? Wieso?
Du kannst doch, kannst du nicht, ja. Haben die nicht offensichtlich Kategorien irgendwo? Torrent verzeichnet das Blättern.
Ist mir eigentlich auch wurscht.
Man hat jede Kategorie einen Namen und ähm.
The Internet is for Porn. Also wir sehen, ich fasse zusammen, wir sind nach wie vor alle ein bisschen desorientiert, was diese Pirate Bay Geschichte betrifft. Es ist einfach irgendwie.
Was auch daran liegt, dass halt die auch, also die Kommunikation, da ist ja sperrlich, die wissen selber auch alle nicht so genau, was sie da machen und deswegen kann man auch gar nicht so viel genau wissen. Also ist alles ein bisschen schräg.
Wir müssen eben noch mal hinterherforschen.
Warten. Es gibt ja diesen knuffigen kleinen Konkurrenten zum Apple namens Palm. Na, hatten wir kurz schon. Genau. Und Palm hat es jetzt nach langen, langen Hin und Her geschafft, das SDK rauszubringen für die große Öffentlichkeit. Ich hab mir das selbstverständlich sofort runtergeladen. Das macht echt einen schicken Eindruck. Insbesondere, wenn man, das nehm ich nicht ganz so abgespeckt wie das iPhone SDK, wo ja wirklich nix dabei ist, wo man gerade mal so das Safari mit starten kann und so was. Beim Palm SDK ist so ziemlich alles dabei, was das richtige Gerät auch hat. Das heißt, man kann da wirklich mal schön mit einem Palm rumspielen, ohne sich gleich einen kaufen zu müssen.
Du meinst, das SDK fürs iPhone hat kein Mail mit dabei, weil es aber für einen Developer keinen Sinn macht, da ein Mail mit zu liefern.
Das hat kein Mail, das hat kein YouTube, das hat kein Memo, das hat eigentlich nichts.
Na wofür brauchst du die auch beim Programmieren nicht? Das Einzige, was du brauchst, sind die Bilder. Und die Bilder sind ja dabei, weil du von deinem Programm auf die Bilder zugreifen musst.
Umst du mir mal anzugucken? Und hier kann ich mir sehr schön jetzt vom Palm mal einen Eindruck machen. Und jetzt ist natürlich so eine Emulation nie so hundertprozentig das wahre. Also es hat den Nachteil, es gibt halt keinen Touch. Also ich meine, das ist schon ein komplett anderes Display, da braucht man jetzt nichts vorzumachen. Auf der anderen Seite hat es den großen Vorteil, dass es natürlich wahnsinnig viel schneller ist.
Das mit dem Touch ist aber bei dem iPhone-Simulator auch so.
Und ich hab damit mal ein bisschen rumgespielt. Also das macht alles schon einen ziemlich guten Eindruck. So auf den ersten Blick. Man startet so einen Assistenten, wo man dann seinen Account eintragen kann. Das ist nicht wie bei Android nur der Google-Account, sondern auch zum Beispiel Facebook-Account. Man kann sehr schön zwischen den Programmen wechseln, wie vorgeschrieben. Und das macht jetzt nicht so den Eindruck, als ob da irgendwie was extrem langsam wäre, oder als ob das da wirklich...
Na ja, das läuft ja oft im Rechner.
Ja, oder als ob da irgendwie Funktionalitäten fehlen würden. Sondern das macht schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob ich dann...
Und die nehmen als Basis auch den Webkit?
Die nehmen als Basis auch den Webkit, genau. Also die haben einen Linux-Opten drunter und oben drauf da ein Webkit. Und da haben wir ja schon mehrfach drüber gesprochen, dieser etwas oder deutlich andere Ansatz.
Also so gesehen ist das eigentlich schon fast ein Chrome OS.
Das ist eigentlich das Chrome OS. Weil das ist ja... Chrome OS ist rausgebracht, das ist komplett. Weil wir haben ja schon ein paarmal gehabt das Thema, das gesamte UI in HTML gebastelt ist und CSS. Und darum sehr stark auf Webtechnologien ausgesetzt. Und was damit möglich ist, ist eigentlich doch sehr beeindruckend, muss ich mal sagen. Also ich meine, hier so ein Kalender, der macht schon was her, finde ich. Und so diese ganzen Programme. Und was ich jetzt noch nicht geschafft habe, mal den Musikplayer zum Laufen zu kriegen, aber ja, das sind halt so Details. Macht auf jeden Fall, wer mit dem Gedanken spielt, sich mal einen Palm zu holen, wenn er dann irgendwann mal Ende des Jahres auch in Deutschland zu haben sein wird, der sollte sich auf jeden Fall schon mal diesen Emulator runterladen. Geht ganz easy. Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, vielleicht noch diesen, kennt ihr Tietanium?
Ich lese gerade so ein bisschen unser Twitter Feedback. Da gibt es durchaus ein paar kluge Sachen. Ich kann ja mal kurz einschieben, bevor wir auf dein Tietanium kommen. Hier wird behauptet, in der Schweiz und auch bei T-Mobile Austria ist tatsächlich Tethering beim iPhone einfach mit dabei, ohne Aufpreis.
Und geht auch schon.
Es sei so. War jetzt hier die Behauptung. Ich habe jetzt keine Quellen, die über Twitter hinausgehen. Als guter Journalist muss ich das alles bezweifeln. Aber das war jetzt so die Aussage. Die mir hier so zugeworfen wird. Dann wird sehr viel gesagt, dass unser Livestream mal wieder abgebrochen ist, wie immer. Und es wird gefragt, was mit den Heerenzielen von Pirate Bay ist. Das können wir euch vielleicht das nächste Mal beantworten. Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß es nicht. So, was ist das Titanium?
Titanium ist so ein bisschen so eine Adobe Air, kennen wir ja alle so ein bisschen.
Adobe Air, so.
Adobe Air, das ist so eine Entwicklungsumgebung, mit der man, wenn wir schon beim Thema WebOS sind, in HTML...
Von wem ist das?
Von Adobe.
Titanium?
Nee, Titanium nicht. Ich erzähl erst mal kurz, was Adobe Air ist, dann komme ich auf Titanium und dann auf...
Haben wir so viel Zeit.
Ja doch, hallo. So, da kann man in HTML und JavaScript und Flash Desktop-Applikation entwickeln. Wir kennen alle bestimmten Programme, die damit geschrieben sind. Zum Beispiel sehr viele Twitter-Clients. Ich glaube, wenn man unter Windows einen vernünftigen Twitter-Client haben will, dann kommt man an Adobe Air gar nicht vorbei. Das ist so eine ganz hübsche Lösung. Jetzt hat ein anderer Hersteller, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie die heißen, was ähnliches gemacht, das soll dann aber Open Source werden. Das heißt Titanium verzichtet dann natürlich auf Flash, sondern verlässt sich komplett auf HTML. Und die haben jetzt eine Version, mit der man auch mobile Applikationen entwickeln kann. Und zwar kann ich mit diesem Titanium-Developer Applikationen sowohl für Android als auch für das iPhone entwickeln. Im Idealfall sogar da in einem Schritt. Die Idealforstellung ist, ich entwickle einmal vor mich hin, mach mein HTML-Code.
Also schreibst du da deinen Code in JavaScript und nutzt da auch die grafischen Elemente, die die da so haben, und dann sagst du hier bau mir mal das Programm und der kann das bauen sowohl fürs iPhone, indem er das dann in Objective-C und deren GUI-Zeugs umsetzt und sowohl aber auch fürs Android das da in Java und so weiter umsetzt.
Genau, ich nehme mal an, das wird einfach nur eine Runtime sein, die da im Hintergrund läuft und mir quasi mein JavaScript-Code live ausführt, aber im Prinzip passt er recht, ja.
Das könnte theoretisch auch, kommt doch an, wie gut dieses Palm-Pré-SD-Cast auch dafür kommen eigentlich.
Ja, ziemlich sicher. Also dafür noch am ehesten. Was das Schöne daran ist, es unterstützt einen Haufen native Elemente. Also das Programm ist auf den ersten Blick, ich hab's hier auf dem iPhone laufen, außer dass es relativ langsam ist, nicht von einem normalen iPhone ab zu unterscheiden. Das macht so einen Eindruck, als ob ich sagen würde, ja, damit möchte ich auch eines Tages mal iPhone-Applikationen entwickeln und wenn nebenbei noch ein Android-Programm herunterfällt, womit ich ehrlich gesagt im Augenblick nicht so wirklich rechne, dann...
Was ist denn da die passende Web-Resource zu diesem Thema?
Die suche ich noch mal raus. Mal nach Titanium googeln.
Na, wenn ich nach Titanium google, was meinste, was da kommt?
Nach Titanium, iPhone und Android googelst du natürlich.
Accelerator heißt der Hersteller.
Drei Worte.
Das ist der zweite Link bei Google, wenn ich Titanium eingebe.
Na, bei dir, mit deinen Prefs. Weil dein Google schon weiß, was du suchst. Bei dem anderen kommt Titanium-Porn.
Accelerator. Und die haben dieses Titanium-Destop quasi. Und auch die mobile Version, die man allerdings über das Early-Adapter-Programm bekommt. Ist auch noch nicht wirklich rund, muss man auch sagen. Hat noch einen Haufen Bugs, aber das wird, hab ich so das Gefühl, kann man bestimmt bei tolle Sachen entwickeln.
Ja, mit JavaScript ist einiges gehen. Da bin ich auch sehr gespannt. Aber diese Cross-OS-Rich-Desktop-Schnickes.
Das hat noch nie so hundertprozentig funktioniert.
Das hat einfach meine Zweifel. Das mag für so ein paar vertikale Geschichten interessant sein. Wenn man jetzt wirklich für irgendeinen schmalbanigen Kunden irgendwas produzieren muss, was halt auf allen Plattformen laufen soll und irgendwie mit wenig Development auskommen soll. Und wo es jetzt nicht so wichtig ist, dass das bis in alle Ewigkeit läuft.
Es hängt davon ab, wie viele native Elemente man einbaut. Also wenn man sagt, ich hab eine Werbeapplikation, die ich sowieso nur für einen Fall nutzen möchte. Also ich war am Wochenende auf dem Meld-Festival und die wollten, die hatten zumindest neben mir im Heft stehen, es gab wohl nicht, aber dass sie eine iPhone-Applikation haben, für sowas ist das natürlich absolut perfekt, dass man dann sagen kann, ja und hier hast du auch noch für Android. Und sieht auf beiden Plattformen da nicht wirklich nativ aus, aber für den Fall reicht.
Nativ genug.
Kunde zahlt.
Oder.
Ja, so war das ja mit Java auch mal, hat sich aber dann irgendwie auch nicht so richtig durchgesetzt am Ende.
Nein, bei Java muss man aber auch sagen, dass es Sanja wirklich auf unglaubliche Art und Weise gelungen ist, dass es gibt ja wirklich kein Java-Programm, das irgendwie gut aussieht. Also es sah ja wirklich auf allen Plattformen genauso scheiße aus.
Das stimmt. Und jetzt, du meinst, das sieht zumindest irgendwie gut aus.
Also das sieht auf dem iPhone sieht das aus wie eine original iPhone-Applikation, und der Android sieht es aus wie eine original Android-Applikation. Das ist natürlich dann die Frage, wie man das hinbiegt, dass wenn man dann irgendwie ein eigenes Element baut oder so, das muss man dann wahrscheinlich doch wieder für beide Plattformen unabhängig entwickeln. Aber ich glaube, oder ich vermute mal, als Entwickler hat man die Möglichkeit, dahinreichend gut drauf einzugehen. Aber ich würde gucken, guck das mal an, das sieht aus wie ein iPhone-Programm.
Zeichnmord. Das ist aber jetzt im Web-Browser oder was?
Nee, nee, das ist... Wo kommt die ab jetzt her? Das ist eine Demo-Applikation, Kitchensank heißt die, und die habe ich jetzt einfach damit installiert.
Jetzt über Jailbreak oder ist das tatsächlich im App Store?
Nee, das ist so, wie man es halt aufs iPhone draufkriegt. Also wenn man Apple-Developer ist, dann kann man es darüber installieren. Oder eben über ein Jailbreak.
Aber es gibt keinerlei Anwendungen, die da drin geschrieben sind, die App Store sind? Aber es ist nur JavaScript, es benutzt nur die Web-Engine.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht genau genug angucken können.
Ich meine, iPhone-Applikationen zu machen, das ist ja das eine, die müssen ja auch redistributierbar sein.
Das ist eine native Applikation, die könntest du dir jetzt auch in App Store einstellen.
Verstehe, das heißt, da ist im Prinzip ein iPhone-Application-Wrapper, der das Programm containt und der eigentliche Code ist dann aber JavaScript, der in der Web-Engine läuft und das da drin. Und das lässt Apple ja auch zu.
Und du kannst eben auf native Elemente zugreifen. Also du kannst deutlich mehr machen, als du in Safari machen könntest.
Native Elemente, sowas wie die Kamera benutzen und GPS.
Kamera benutzen, GPS benutzen, Accelerator benutzen, du kannst die Toolbar, also die ganzen GUI-Sachen nutzen, die native Applikation nutzen können, also oben die Toolbar, unten die Leiste, die ganzen Listen-Elemente. Filme spielt er ab. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass auch Push-Notifications kommen werden, also kann man damit schon mal wirklich sehr, sehr viel entwickeln.
Na gut, Titanium.
Das geht weiter mit den Web-Applikationen.
Ja, da bin ich mir auch sicher. Aber ich sag euch, wie es ist, Leute, ich bin müde.
Die Quarterly Results sind draußen. Und das ist das beste, nicht Non-Holiday-Quarter ever.
Wieder mal. Das letzte schon.
Ja, ist immer best ever. Sagen ja auch immer, dass jetzt die schnellsten Macs rauskommen. Ich warte ja auch auf den Tag, wo sie mal sagen, unser Mac ist diesmal nicht so schnell wie letztes Mal.
Während wir die Sendung machen, kommen einfach die Dings raus. Das heißt, wir können ja sogar vor dem FSDK-Log schon drüber berichten.
Ach, Quatsch. Und Apple Insider hat das vor 46 Minuten.
Leo, du alte Sau. Du bist wirklich... Also, ich bin froh... Ich bin froh, dass ich kein Mac-Blogger bin.
Den wie Leo anzukommen, das wäre die Hölle, oder?
Das frustriert total irgendwie.
Das hab ich ihm schon mal irgendwann persönlich gesagt.
Ich glaub, das haben wir sogar beide gesagt, oder nicht?
Also, bei Mobile Max, als wir noch gebloggt haben und ich diesen Podcast gemacht hab, wenn ich mal es mir gelungen ist, zu irgendeinem absurd kryptischen Thema vier Minuten vor Leo zu sein, dann war ich wirklich, wirklich stolz auf mich.
Ja, das hat keinen Sinn. Erneutes Rekordquartal. Das lesen wir einfach mal FSDK-Log vor. Was haben wir denn hier? 8,... Hat er auch schon die tollen Grafiken? Nee.
Jetzt können wir mal direkt mit Nokia vergleichen einfach.
Na, es ist so ein ähnlicher Umsatz. Also 8,34 Milliarden. Nokia hat 9,9.
Genau.
1,23 Milliarden US-Talanotto-Gewinn. Da hat Nokia ein Fünftel davon. Genau. Brutto-Gewinnspanne 36,3 Prozent. Das ist auch echt so absurd. Also was die wirklich da für Margen reinmachen. 2,6 Millionen Max. Das ist viel. Das ist mehr als, ist das nicht die höchste Zahl? Haben die schon mal mehr als 2,6 Millionen? Waren die schon mal in 3 Millionen dran?
Keine Ahnung, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Und 10 Millionen iPods. Das scheint ja irgendwie die Zahl zu sein, die sich irgendwie mehr oder weniger hält. Auch wenn es 7 Prozent weniger ist als im Vorjahresquartal. Verkaufte iPhones. Was? 5,2 Millionen iPhones? Das bezieht sich jetzt auf welchen Zeitraum? April bis Ende Juni. Das heißt, da ist im Prinzip, wann ist das neue iPhone rausgekommen?
Das ist gar nicht dabei.
Das ist da noch nicht wirklich grundsätzlich.
Das ist Anfang Juli draufgekommen.
Das heißt, sie haben sechsmal so viele iPhones verkauft wie letztes Jahr. Das heißt, während das alte First-Generation-iPhone im letzten Jahr dann nicht mehr so richtig ankam und alle schon das nächste haben wollten, haben sie in diesem Jahr noch mal ganz gut zugeschlagen. Das ist wirklich langweilig, dass sie einfach immer nur, ich meine, das ist auch wirklich unfassbar. Da ist jetzt irgendwie Krise und was machen die? Die machen einfach so weiter wie bisher. Ja, das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich. Aber ich muss sagen, es ist auch nachvollziehbar. Das neue Line-up mit den Laptops und so weiter. Also die Rechnerplattform sah meiner Meinung nach noch nie so gut aus. Also sie haben einfach wirklich ein sehr gutes Angebot. Und mit dem neuen iPhone ist das natürlich auch nochmal ein Thema. Wobei das spielt ja jetzt hier noch gar nicht rein. Aber die neuen Laptops sind hier wahrscheinlich schon mit drin. Zumindest ein Stück weit. Wann sind die vorgestellt worden? Das war im Juni, oder?
Ach, man weiß es nicht. Ich probiere gerade rauszukriegen, wie viele Smartphones Nokia verkauft hat in der selben Zeit. Also sie haben natürlich unglaublich viel mehr Geräte verkauft, nämlich 268 Millionen ungefähr Nokia im selben Zeitraum. Nokia hat etwa 268 Millionen Telefone verkauft im selben Zeitraum. Aber ich finde leider nirgendswo zahlend zum...
Wie viele Smartphones sie verkauft haben.
Wie viele Smartphones. Aber da im Durchschnitt verkaufte Nokia ein Gerät für 62. Bei Smartphones habe das Unternehmen seinen Marktanteil auf 41% steigern können.
Tja, also da kann ich jetzt nicht so richtig viel reinlesen hier in die Zahlen, außer dass die irgendwie ganz gut sind.
Äppel, hier geht's durfter. Was natürlich ein Nebensatz ist, dass die Jobs das gesagt hat.
Aber wenn ich das hier so richtig sehe, also 2,6 Millionen hatten sie schon mal. 2,6 Millionen haben sie nämlich im Weihnachtsquartal gehabt.
Das ist das best non-holiday-Quartal.
Naja, das heißt, sie sind ja gut nach Geld. Aber ich beziehe es jetzt explizit auf die MEX. Das heißt, die haben es geschafft, genauso viele MEX jetzt zu verkaufen mit einem Jahr wie Weihnachten.
Achso, und das Weihnachtsquartal war das beste aller Zeiten?
Ich beziehe mich jetzt ausschließlich auf die Stückzahl von MEX. Nicht, was sie jetzt da an Geld gemacht haben, sondern einfach, was da sozusagen an Geräten auf den Markt geworfen wurde. Und weil ich erwarte ja ehrlich gesagt schon noch, dass diese Kurve in den nächsten Jahren signifikant steigt. Jetzt gab es halt diesen Peak beim letzten Weihnachten, wo sie das erste Mal über zwei sechs rübergegangen sind und ich wage jetzt mal die Aussage, die Vermutungen, die Wette, dass sie dieses Jahr Weihnachten knacken sie die drei Millionen. Also wenn nicht schon vorher. Das ist jetzt fällig.
Wenn dann das Tablet-Ding draußen ist und das Netbook.
Ach ja, Tablet. Zum Abschluss können wir ja noch mal in die Glaskugel gucken. Vorhin sind es ja auch, hast du ja schon gesagt hier, was war das? Der neue iPod Touch?
Ach so, ja, neuer iPod Touch. War der nicht schon mal mitzumachen aktuell? Mit Kamera vermutlich.
Haben wir aber glaube ich nicht drüber geredet.
Haben wir keine Sekunde drüber geredet, aber ja, da wird ein neuer iPod Touch kommen und der wird dann auf 3G-S-Niveau sein und wird ne Kamera haben und wird ein Mikrofon haben, aber wird immer noch genau so...
Bist du dir sicher bei der Kamera? Ist das jetzt von dem, was du gehört hast oder was du meinst?
Das ist von dem, was ich gehört habe und das liegt in der Natur der Sache, würde ich sagen.
Na gut, bisher hatten sie keine Kamera.
Bisher hatten sie keine Kamera, aber ich glaube, die wollen, wenn es... Ich glaube, das soll eine möglichst einheitliche Plattform werden. Da sollen möglichst viele Features, die das eine hat, soll das andere haben und dieses Dedicated Lauter-Leiser-Button, die sie ja schon bei der zweiten Generation gehabt haben, weil gerade Spiele, da konnte man, während man das Spiel gespielt hat, nicht die Lautstärke einstellen, weil die Entwickler alle iPhones hatten und einfach über die Lauter-Leiser-Button das gemacht haben.
Gut, aber ein Lauter-Leiser-Button und eine Kamera ist eine andere Geschichte.
Na, vom Preis her wahrscheinlich nicht so wirklich und...
Wir machen jetzt noch gerade noch ein bisschen Glaskuhl, Dennis.
iPod Touch Kamera.
Also, Marc sagt, er wird eine Kamera haben. Was meinst du?
Billig, kostet nichts.
Na billig ist es bestimmt, nee.
Naja, relativ.
Relativ zu was? Also relativ zu keiner Kamera ist es teurer?
Relativ auch zum iPod-Preis.
Naja gut, weiß ja wieder. Naja, das ist schon nicht wenig, aber ich glaube auch... Also ich glaube trotzdem, dass sie es reinbauen werden. Und zwar einerseits aus demselben Grund, was du meinst, Marc, dass es für sie auch von Vorteil ist, wenn sie eben auch an der Plattform eine Kamera haben. Das macht einfach den iPod Touch interessanter. Ich meine sogar auch, dass sie das schon immer haben wollten, aber dass sie einfach sich nicht getraut haben, die schlechte Kamera von dem 3G da einzubauen. Und jetzt, wo sie dieses neue Kameramodell gefunden haben, mit diesem manuellen Fokus und Helligkeitsbestimmung und so weiter und eben auch mit der Videofunktionalität, dass sie das eben jetzt auch damit reinbringen. Das heißt, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie auch die volle Bild- und Videofunktionalität übernehmen und dass das Teil halt dementsprechend ganz schön heißes Eisen wird. Ja und sonst noch? GPS ist halt die Frage.
GPS, genau das wollte ich sagen, ist die eigentlich spannende Frage, wie ich finde.
Und Kompass natürlich.
Ich glaube es nicht. Also ich glaube, dass sie das irgendwie nicht machen, weil ihr GPS ist nur deswegen gut, weil es A-GPS ist, nur deswegen hat es einen schnellen Fix und so weiter.
Na ja, aber das ist natürlich beim WLAN auch ganz okay.
Beim WLAN, A-GPS, die machen über A-GPS, die holen sich das übers Internet?
Die haben auch, die haben auch, du kannst da auch, also du hast ja die Positionierung schon jetzt im iPod und die verlässt sich rein auf WLAN.
Ja gut, aber die Frage ist, wie schnell kriegst du deinen Fix und deinen GPS fix? Und den kriegst du dadurch halt schnell, dass du eben vom Mobilfunk...
Nein, das ist schon eine grobe Position vorher.
Genau, das ist schon etwa mit den Zählen, weiß...
Und die kannst du ja genauso gut aus dem WLAN holen.
Ja gut, du kriegst ja sozusagen auch die Satellitenbahnen vorberechnet. Das ist mir durchaus vorstellbar, dass sie denselben, dieselbe Dienstleistung quasi auch im Internet haben. Aber dann muss das Ding ja auch Internet haben und das hat halt so ein iPod-Touch in der Regel eben nicht. Das heißt, du stehst dann im Zweifelsfall rum und hast einfach kein Internet. Und auch diese ganze Ortung funktioniert halt nur, wenn du Internet hast. Also ich bin mir da nicht so sicher.
Ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher.
Ich fände es cool, aber ich glaube diese GPS-Geschichte, die wird noch im iPhone alleine verbleiben.
So ein Slot für eine UMTS-Karte in so einem iPod-Touch, das wäre mal der Hammer.
Ja, so und das andere Gerät, was noch kommt?
Also an die dritte Variante dazwischen, das so ein Touch-Tablet, was jetzt ja irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen mal kurz wieder hochkochte.
Ja, aus denselben Gründen wie schon seit drei Jahren. Alle reden die ganze Zeit darüber.
Die jetzt ja auch, glaube ich, nach wie vor nicht dran.
Bin mir nicht so sicher. Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, die hauen irgendein Gerät raus mit circa doppelt oder dreimal so groß wie ein iPhone.
Dreimal so groß wie ein iPhone?
Naja, doppelt ist jetzt noch nicht so viel, aber so...
Also nicht dreimal so breit und dreimal so langsam.
Drei Mal verdoppelt, viermal so groß.
Dreimal nebeneinander und dann quer.
So wie unsere drei iPhones nebeneinander gelegt.
Ja, oder vielleicht sogar so eher.
Alle Hörer wissen, was gemeint ist. Also wir liegen hier drei iPhones nebeneinander. So groß wie drei iPhones nebeneinander. Wo steckt man sich das hin?
Das ist vielleicht der Grund, warum Apple auch denkt, dass es eigentlich Blödsinn ist.
Lass mal dein iPhone mal hier, gib mal her.
Für die Hosentasche zu klein und also für die Hosentasche zu groß und für alles anderes ist zum Nutzen irgendwie zu klein. Das kann schon sein. Aber ich meine zum Lesen so, weil wenn ich Bücher lese, dann wär's...
Damit kannst du Webseiten geil lesen.
Genau. Und Bücher und alles.
Ich könnte es mir für den Bildungsbereich ganz spannend vorstellen. So für Unis oder für Schulen.
Aber dann sind wir ja bei dem E-Book-Reader. Bloß das ist dann natürlich ein Top-Notch-E-Book-Reader mit all möglichen Chat-Wi-Ri-S. Vielleicht sogar auch wirklich mit GSM, UMTS, tralala drin. Weil was soll ich mit so einem Stupid-Device, was sonst nichts kann, außer irgendwie Sachen darstellen, die sonst auf Papier sind.
Ja, aber das Ding müsste ja eine riesen Bildschirmauflösung haben.
Ja, geil, oder?
Also ich meine, wenn man da mal etwa in die Zukunft denkt, dann könnte man sicher sagen, in welche Tasche will man das stecken? Natürlich in die, die Top-Designer speziell für dieses Gerät bauen werden. Weil wenn Apple wirklich ein geiles Gerät baut, dann werden dafür auch die Taschen produziert. Dann werden die ganzen jungen Hipster alle mit speziellen Eye-Tablet-Taschen durch die Gegend.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja klar, weil das spielt ja keine Rolle. Die Frage ist, was ist der Markt? Was ist der Markt dafür? Und würde ich mir das kaufen? Also was sollte mich dazu bringen, so ein Teil mitzuschleppen?
Apple ist ja nicht blöd. Die bringen ja nicht einfach irgendwas raus und verlassen sich dann, dass Leute schon irgendwie cool finden, sondern die bringen ja gleich die komplette Infrastruktur und alles, was man haben will, bringen die ja immer gleich mit, sodass es halt auch Sinn macht.
Und da denke ich mal, bei Apple ist das schon gegeben. Also für mich ist das iPhone, das ist mein, also das iPhone übernimmt bei mir jetzt die Arbeit, die vor ein paar Jahren der Laptop gemacht hat. Der Laptop hat nämlich...
Du bist noch nicht hauptsächlich mit dem iPhone am Surfen, oder? Also ist das richtig so, Surfen, Surfen?
Was heißt Surfen, Surfen? Na so wie vor ein paar Jahren. Mein mobiler Netzbedarf, der war damals auch sehr eingeschränkt.
Wirklich?
Na ja klar. Ich kann schon jede Webseite anwählen. Die Frage ist nur, sind es Webseiten, mit denen du dann viel rum interagierst, oder ist es mehr Information Retrieval? Das kann ich mit dem iPhone auch machen.
Ich finde das ist auf dem iPhone immer noch relativ...
Klar, aber ich sag dir einfach wie es ist. Früher war es so, ich war froh, dass ich einen Laptop hab, weil ich konnte das Haus verlassen und hatte trotzdem noch Computing. Und irgendwann hatte ich dann sogar auch irgendwie Internet oder ich konnte zumindest meinen Arbeitsplatz verlagern, so. Und da wir ja alle verrückte Nerds sind, hatte ich dieses Teil irgendwie immer dabei. Egal wo ich hingegangen bin, ich hatte immer meinen Computer dabei. Auch wenn ich ihn vielleicht gar nicht benutzt hab. Aber der Gedanke, meinen Computer zu Hause zu haben und dann irgendwann im Laufe des Tages mal kein Netz zu haben, obwohl es welches gäbe oder irgendwas nachzuschlagen oder auch nur irgendeine Software benutzen zu können, um da eine Information drin zu versenken, hat mich gekillt. Also war das Ding immer dabei. Deswegen wollte ich so einen kleinen Laptop haben. Deswegen hab ich das MacBook.
So ein iPhone ist also ein bisschen wie ein Nikotinpflaster.
Genau. Seitdem ich das iPhone habe, ist der Primary Urge irgendwie weg. Also ich brauche dann den Computer nicht mehr dabei. Klar wäre er manchmal dann besser, aber das iPhone ist irgendwie good enough. Wenn jetzt so ein Gerät, so ein Tablett zwischen dem iPhone und dem Computer rauskommt und es ist mehr wie ein iPhone, dann weiß ich nicht so richtig, ob ich dann wirklich nur, weil es einen größeren Bildschirm hat, das Teil mitschleppen würde oder nicht sage, ach, da bin ich mit meinem iPhone auch zufrieden damit, kriege ich die Webseite mit.
Das ist ja nicht die Frage, ob das Ding gegen ein iPhone ankämpft. Dein iPhone hast du sowieso immer dabei, weil das ist dein Telefon. Aber das würde gegen den Rechner ankämpfen.
Aber die Frage ist, tut es das konzeptionell dadurch, dass es so ist wie ein iPhone oder tut es das konzeptionell, indem es so ist wie ein Mac OS?
Es ist genau dazwischen halt.
Ja gut, aber in welche Richtung entwickelt es sich? Ist es eher ein Touchscreen und ist es iPhone OS oder ist es doch eine Art Netbook und hat irgendwie eine Tastatur optional und ist halt mit Mac OS?
Na, ich würde sagen, es ist auch eine Mischung von beim. Ich würde sagen, es kommt ganz so an, wie du das halt so siehst.
Also ich würde sagen, es ist ein iPhone.
Ja, aber was ist der Use-Case? Wer ist der Markt?
Bildungsmarkt.
Ja, wie groß ist der Bildungsmarkt?
Der Bildungsmarkt ist gigantisch.
Ja, aber ich bitte dich, Max, Bill Gates redet seit zehn Jahren von dieser Scheiße, was diese Tablets alles bewirken können. Passiert ist nichts.
Ja, weil die alles scheiße waren.
Nein, weil es auch einfach niemanden gibt in der Breite, der das wirklich macht. Bildungsmarkt, klar, okay, Krankenhäuser und so weiter, aber das sind alles vertikale Märkte. Das ist kein Horizontarmer.
Potenziale wie Breite. Also es gibt ja schon viele, also zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt seit heute gibt es eine Applikation für, oder seit ein paar Tagen, für das iPhone, das ist, die nennt sich Layers, das ist irgendwie so quasi so ein Photoshop fürs iPhone. Das heißt, da kann man ein bisschen mit dem Finger drin rummalen.
Auf dem iPhone kann man nicht wirklich, das ist alles zu klein.
Aber was ist der Markt?
Moment mal, es hat jetzt, es hat jemand für das New Yorker das Cover auf dem iPhone gemalt. Also für ein Print-Zeitungsmagazin. Warte mal, war das ein Thema? Also das ist, das ist, es gibt Leute, die sehen das, ah, ich kann mit dem Finger malen, geile Anwendung, das ist der Vorteil gegenüber meinem Mac. Und dass ich das einfach ein bisschen größer habe, mit ein bisschen, also Touch, mit einem großen Display.
Ja gut, aber Bilder malen ist jetzt echt kein Massenmarkt.
So, das ist Bilder malen, das ist Surfen. Surfen kannst du nicht gut mit dem iPhone.
Doch, zu klein.
Das ist zu klein. Nee, nicht good enough.
Es ist, es ist doch.
Nein, nicht für mich. Also ich surfe.
Ja, aber was, was, was, ist es ein Problem der Größe oder ist es ein Problem der fehlenden Tastatur? Wie stört mir die Tastatur?
Die Tastatur stört mich null beim Surfen. Es ist geschwindig.
URLs eintippen.
Wie oft tippe ich meine URL ein?
Ich tippe immer auf einen Meter URLs ein.
Die meisten Sachen habe ich gebookmarkt, wenn es da eine vernünftige Autocompletion gibt. Die, die...
Tastatur ist nicht das Problem.
Das Problem ist die Größe, dass ich immer so komisch scrollen muss und rein- und rauszoomen muss.
Größe des Displays und Geschwindigkeit ist ein ganz wichtiges Sache.
Na, Geschwindigkeit wird mit dem 3GR so okay sein, nehme ich mal an.
Ähm, bin ich mal gespannt, ob sie gut genug wird. So, ähm, und dass ich kann, dass die Tabs so funktionieren, wie sie funktionieren. Also das ist auch was, was man über mehr RAM lösen kann. Das sehe ich als großer Nachteil.
Ist auch beim 3GR nicht gemacht.
Dann Bildungsmarkt Schulbücher lesen drauf, weil Schulbücher, die braucht man dann nicht mehr zu drucken, die kann man leicht aktualisieren, da kann man dann auch mal in der Wikipedia nachschlagen, etc.
Aber Schüler, die müssen auch wieder dazu schreiben und so.
Du kriegst doch nicht so ein, ich meine, was würde dieses Teil kosten, wenn ein iPhone 600 Dollar kostet? Was kostet dann ein DIN A5-iPhone mit denselben Features, mit UMTS und Pipi-Papa-Pop?
Wieso?
Das kostet 1000, 200, 1000, 500, natürlich.
Ich meine, was kostet denn?
Da ist viel mehr Akku drin, da ist viel mehr Bildschirm drin, da ist einfach viel mehr Hardware drin.
Na wie, nee, nee, nee, Moment mal, Moment mal, Moment mal.
Also du brauchst... Na klar, ist das da drin.
Also du brauchst ein größeres, du brauchst ein großes Display.
Da ist extrem Stromspulver.
Aber warte, das wird nicht ganz so viel teurer, weil sie müssen ja dann nicht ein ganz so hochauflösendes nehmen.
Nicht nur das, ich meine, ein Netbook kostet so...
Na ja, klar, sie werden nicht in der Auflösung deutlich runtergehen. Ja, aber es gibt da auch gar nichts, was niedriger auflässt.
Ja, aber ein Netbook kostet von anderen Herstellern...
Von anderen Herstellern...
.kostet 4 bis 500 Euro.
Da ist ja auch nur Trash drin.
Dann hat man schon ein gutes Netbook. Mehr bräuchte, dann schmeißt du die Tastatur weg. Das hat einen vernünftigen Prozessor, das ist hier so ein Intel Atom-Prozessor, der definitiv mehr kann als so ein ARM-Ding. Dann kannst du billigere Akkutechnologie nutzen, weil du ein größeres Gerät hast, weil du mehr Platz drin hast.
Das brauchst du ja auch mehr Saft da für deinen Atom.
Ja, aber dann lässt du halt... Was ist das große Problem beim iPhone? Ist das ganze UMTS-Zeug, das Telefon-Zeug. Das lässt du dann weg und sagst, WLAN hat jede Schule und jede Uni. Punkt.
Also wenn das Ding noch nicht mal Internet hat...
WLAN.
Also wenn das Ding... ja, aber... ne. Also dann wird es für mich richtig uninteressant, weil...
Na doch, das ist wie mit iPod Touch. Also ich meine, der verkauft sich auch nicht schlecht. Und hat auch nur WLAN.
Also wir reden eher von einem großen iPod Touch als von einem iPhone.
Gut. Klar.
So, das heißt, das Ding müsste aber wirklich, um genauso attraktiv zu sein, müsste es auch dem Spielemarkt sozusagen gewogen sein. Wäre es wahrscheinlich auch. So, bei Design. Tja, was kostet iPod Touch?
300?
Ist auch ziemlich teuer.
270 oder sowas, glaube ich.
Tja, also mit anderen Worten, für den Preis des iPhones, 600 Euro, würde es wahrscheinlich das große Teil kriegen.
Ich würde fast sagen, das ist auch 500 bis 700.
Aber jetzt irgendwie Schulen, Schulen sind in dem Sinne kein wirklicher Markt, weil das ist natürlich für eine Schule kaum zu leisten. Schüler könnten ein Markt sein, aber das ist auch für einen Schüler kaum zu leisten.
Naja, das ist relativ...
Ich meine, das findet... Ich glaube, in Kalifornien haben sie jetzt beschlossen, keine Schulbücher mehr rauszugeben, alles nur noch elektronisch zu machen, aber das machen sie nicht, weil es toller ist, sondern weil sie Geld sparen wollen. Damit werden sie einfach auf die Schnauze fallen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie oft man so ein Schulbuch austauschen muss, wie oft sie dafür bezahlen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie lange so ein E-Book wieder in meiner Schulzeit ausgehalten hätte.
Das muss dann...
Was machst du dann? Dann kannst du dir kein Gerät leisten. Wer kauft dir eins? Dann ist es kaputt, es ist weg, es ist geklaut, dann hast du keine Schulbücher mehr. Also ich glaub das einfach nicht, dass ich das wirklich...
Na ja, aber das Problem hast du mit jedem Taschenrechner.
Ja, aber ein Taschenrechner ist irgendwie ein billiges Teil. Das kriegst du für irgendwie 1,95 Euro nachgeschmissen.
Und welche Uni war das? Also es gibt ja Unis, die ihren Studenten... Okay, das sind dann teure Unis, das sind dann diese amerikanischen Unis.
Ja, Unis sind nicht Schulen.
Jaja, aber es gibt Unis, die ihren Studenten erst mal als allererstes, wenn du hinkommst, drücken, die dir ein iPhone oder ein iPod Touch in die Hand.
Ja, das sind die Unis, die mehr Geld in der Finanzkrise verloren haben, als allen Universitäten in Deutschland insgesamt im Jahr an Geld zur Verfügung steht. Das sind Elite-Universitäten mit scheiße viel Kohle. Das ist einfach mal nicht der Markt. Wenn wir von einem Gerät reden, was Apple rausbringt, dann muss sich das potenziell in einem Jahr siebenstellig verkaufen.
Also Apple hat ja nun wirklich über eine alte Tradition darin, Geräte speziell für den Bildungsmarkt anzubieten. Ich meine, es gab dieses Newton-Ding, dieses E-Mate-Teil.
Ja, aber das sind nur billige Varianten. Ja, aber das war kein Erfolg.
Das war kein Erfolg. Es gab den E-Mac ewig lange.
Das sind aber nur billige Varianten von Technologie, die sie eh haben. Das sind einfach Auslaufmodelle, die sie länger bauen. Da ist nichts speziell drin. Da ist nur billiger drin.
Das kleine MacBook existiert wahrscheinlich auch noch.
Bei diesem Tablett reden wir doch von einem D-Box-Gerät. Und wir reden vor allem von einem High-Appeal-Teil und nicht von einem Billig-Teil.
Wieso soll das nicht billig sein?
Das wird es einfach nicht sein. Weil Apple einfach 35% Marge drauf haben will. Warum sollten sie das bauen, wenn sie damit kein Geld verdienen wollen?
Sie wollen damit Geld verdienen, aber an wem?
Wer ist der Markt? Das ist meine Frage. Wer ist der Markt? Jetzt kommen die mit Schulen.
Die Schulen, die sich im Augenblick Macbooks kaufen, die sie 900 Dollar kosten, die müssen in Zukunft...
Ja, die kaufen sich trotzdem Macbooks. Die kaufen sich nicht so ein Scheißteil. Die brauchen alle Macbooks und die kaufen sich nicht noch so ein Ding daneben.
Warum brauchen die Macbooks? Wofür brauchen die Macbooks?
Um tippen zu können. Schreiben.
Stell dir mal vor, ein Display in der...
Ich kauf mir da sofort ein Laptop. Ich sag's dir, ich kauf mir nicht so ein komisches Teil.
Ja, du liest ja auch Bücher.
Ich lese keine Bücher. Ich lese eine Zeitung mal. Ja. So. Bücher lese ich nicht. Aber wenn ich welche lese, lese ich sie auf Papier. Die Frage ist doch, was kann das Gerät sein zwischen dem iPhone oder dem iPod Touch und dem Laptop? Und was ist der Markt dafür, der weder auch von dem iPhone abgedeckt werden könnte, als auch von einem billigen Laptop?
Ich sehe genau der Markt dazwischen. Also das Schuhen. Das Surfgerät, das ich fast immer bei mir habe.
Nein, wer? Welche Männer?
Ich zum Beispiel.
Du bist doch kein Markt.
Alle, die sich so Netbook-Dings kaufen würden.
Was?
Alle, die sich so Netbook-Dings kaufen würden. Aber ich glaube schon auch, dass Apple genau weiß, dass alle, die sich so Netbook kaufen, so wie du ja auch welche hattest, zwei sogar oder eins? Ja, das ist halt immer nur so eine kurze Phase, weil die Leute es natürlich schon geil finden, weil sie denken, es wird schon alles gehen und merken dann ein, zwei Monate, länger meistens nicht.
Wenn du dir ein Netbook kaufst, dann steht das hier einmal auf dem Tisch und danach sieht man es nie wieder. Du benutzt es ja nicht. Das gammelt jetzt irgendwie im Regal rum.
Ich hab das zu Hause als Zweiträuchner.
Und das glaube ich, das ist das, was Apple aussieht, dass die Dinger nach einer Weile im Regal rumgammeln.
Warum läufst du denn hier mit deinem Schlachtschiff auf?
Weil ich ein vernünftiges Trackpad haben will in erster Linie. Genau.
Weil du alles vernünftig haben willst.
Ja, aber das heißt nicht, dass man das zum einen –reden wir nicht davon, ob Apple ein Netbook baut –sondern, wie gesagt, ich finde, es ist ein dramatischer …Was brauch ich hier während der Sendung? Ich brauch einen Browser und ich brauch einen Twitter-Client und ich muss kurze Nachrichten tippen können, ich muss mir ein paar Notizen machen können. Das ist so was, was ich perfekt auf so einem Zwischengerät machen könnte. So was in der Richtung.
Ja, aber trotzdem …Ja, weil es dieses Zwischengerät nicht gibt.
Also willst du mir doch nicht …Aber bei dem Netbook ist das Trackpad total scheiße.
Wenn es so ein Tablett geben würde, dann würdest du hier immer noch mit deinem scheiß MacBook sitzen.
Vielleicht würde ich immer noch damit sitzen, aber vielleicht würde ich …Du hättest auch noch eins.
Du würdest dir nicht keinen MacBook kaufen.
Ja, also …Entschuldigung, aber bitte bloß, weil ich ein iPhone habe, habe ich den ja auch immer noch im MacBook.
Ich bin nicht überzeugt. Ich glaube einfach, dass derzeit der Laptop mit der Tastatur und einem großen Bildschirm und dazu das iPhone, die weit voneinander entfernt sind, dass die sich einfach sehr viel besser ergänzen als irgendein Hybrid dazwischen.
Ich sage ja auch nichts von einem Hybrid. Du hast komplett absurde Vorstellungen davon.
Was? Wieso? Ich will keinen Hybrid. Wenn es die Größe vom Netbook hat, aber die Bedienung vom iPhone, dann ist es so ein Hybrid. Oder irgendwas dazu.
Kleiner als ein Netbook.
Also ich könnte mir das eigentlich ganz cool vorstellen, aber ich denke auch, dass schon allein der Kostenpreis, das wird bestimmt eher mehr kosten als 600 Euro, dass das dafür als dann keiner kauft.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Aber ich meine, was, Dennis, sag du doch mal, was würdest du denn, vermisst du was? Was vermisst du?
Wobei jetzt?
Na, so bei deinem Computing-Bedarf. Du hast jetzt ein mobiles Leben, Mobile Max, hier sind wir ja. So, du hast ein iPhone und du hast einen MacBook Pro. Was hättest du denn eigentlich lieber als das?
Also, was ich irgendwie ganz toll finde, ist halt viel Display. Und natürlich ist es auch toll, wenn es ein ganz kleiner Rechner wäre, wie jetzt so ein MacBook Pro 13 Zoll. Das wär schon schick, haben ja manche Leute, seh ich und denk ich auch, das ist schön geil, schön klein, schön klein im Rucksack, das ist schön leicht. Aber da ich mein Rechner auch ganz viel zuhause nutze, obwohl da steht ja eigentlich mal das Display an. Eigentlich könnte ich mir auch ein kleines 13 Zoll holen. Ja, brauch ich schon. Touch wär auch cool.
Mit Mac OS? Oder mit iPhone OS?
Beides.
Na, welches OS hättest du denn lieber?
Na, eine Mischung von beiden. Wenn ich jetzt hier mein Fenster mit irgendwie Finger verschieben könnte, wär das schon auch cool.
Das würdest du nicht tun.
Weißt du, warum Flight Control so cool ist? Weil das Spiel könnte man mit einer Maus überhaupt gar nicht spielen. Das wär nicht das Gleiche. Das ist echt ein Unterschied, wenn da so ein Flieger ankommt oder mit dem Finger einfach mal so du fliegst jetzt mal hier lang. Das geht so viel schneller als mit der Maus irgendwie Ziele treffen.
Aber was ich meine ist, die Laptop-Bauform, wo der Bildschirm mehr oder weniger senkrecht vor dir steht, da willst du nicht drauf rumtouchen. Sondern touchen tust du nur, wenn das wirklich entweder fest in deiner Hand ist oder fest auf dem Tisch liegt.
Das heißt, wenn es gerade auf dem Tisch liegt, du meinst auf dem Display, was steht, wenn man nicht rumtouchen.
Hast du Touch, hast du keine Tastatur. Das ist das, was ich sagen will. Es sei denn, klar, Bluetooth-Tastatur und so weiter, das wäre halt die andere Möglichkeit. Also wenn so ein Ding größer wäre und es hätte eine Bluetooth-Tastatur und so, würde ich mir das auch überlegen. Ehrlich gesagt, was ich derzeit am meisten will, ist einfach Bluetooth-Tastatur fürs iPhone.
Aber wofür brauchst du...
Dafür wäre ich wirklich...
Was tippst du den ganzen Tag?
Was ich tippe? Na, Texte zum Beispiel.
Was denn für Texte?
White Papers und Überlegungen und lange E-Mails und irgendwie noch mehr lange E-Mails und noch mehr lange E-Mails.
Also bei mir gibt es... Source-Code. Es gibt Momente, in denen ich... Ich glaube nicht, dass ich auf so einem Netbook oder Tablet oder wie auch immer, dass ich da Software entwickle oder HTML-Code oder irgendwie sowas. Das nicht. Aber für meine normalen Surf-Gewohnheiten, also für Artikellesen, dass ich... Also ich vermisse es schon. Ich vermisse schon die Zwischenform. Ich vermisse das Gerät, was ich so auf dem Schoß haben kann und wo ich mit zwei Fingern scrollen kann. Ich vermisse so diese Möglichkeit, mit irgendwie mal rummalen zu können. Ich kann mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass es so eine neue Anwendung gibt. Ich kann jetzt keine Märkte damit beschreiben, aber nehmen wir mal an zum Beispiel DJs, die einfach ein virtuelles Instrument auf so einem kleinen Display hätten. Klar, die gibt es schon für das iPhone, solche Programme. Aber warum, da wäre ein größeres Display von Wert.
Ja, also ich kann mir auch tausend Ideen ausmalen, wo so ein Gerät sinnvoll wäre. Aber das ist ja nicht die Frage, die ich gestellt habe.
Auf Filme gucken wäre in der Größe langsam okay, aber auf dem kleinen iPhone kriege ich Augenschmerzen, da muss ich zu nahe ranfokussieren.
Ich gucke mir ja das...
Also ich gucke mir keine Filme auf dem iPhone an?
Ich gucke mir Fernsehserien ohne Ende an.
Echt?
Zum einschlafen und so, wo ich nicht mit so einem riesen Teil ins Bett gehen wollen würde. Auf dem iPhone kann ich auch Probleme mit einpennen. Auf dem großen Teil kann ich nicht mehr einpennen. Weil dann liegst du auf so einem Stück Glas, das wäre ein bisschen zu groß.
Das ist nur ein Argument.
Ich hab schon mehrfach das schiebe ich dann zur Not, diskret und das Kissen, wenn ich noch wach genug bin. Ansonsten liege ich halt drauf. Stört nicht so. Aber so ein großes Teil. Ich bin mir sicher, die Diskussion, die wir hier führen, die führen die bei Apple auch schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Vielleicht konnten sie es bisher aber noch nicht so gut.
Das Internet ist schon wieder weg und ich glaube, wir machen jetzt auch einfach mal Schluss. Was meinst du denn? Jungs, wir haben genug geredet und Mädels.
Also ich glaube auch nicht daran, dass dieses Tablet kommen wird, aber so wie du die eben gerade die drei iPhones nebeneinander gelegt hast, habe ich mir da schon durchaus was vorstellen können.
Ich denke auch. Also ich finde, Apple sollte mal so einen Prototypen bauen, sollen uns mal die ganzen Software dazuschreiben.
Sollen uns den zuschicken.
Sollen uns den zuschicken. Und wir sagen, ob wir es bauen sollen oder nicht. Wir benutzen das mal irgendwie ein halbes Jahr oder ein Monat oder zwei.
Und dann möchte ich Tim sehen, wir sagen, ne, brauch ich nicht.
Und dann sagen wir, ob es gut ist oder nicht. Ich meine, gut ist ein Gerät, wenn es das schafft, dass ich es benutze und denke, oh shit, MacBook Pro lässt du heute mal zu Hause, nimmst du mal das kleine Ding mit. Dann haben sie es geschafft, ein Produkt zu entwickeln.
Also das iPhone schafft das ja in einigen Gelegenheiten sogar.
Wie Tim schon gesagt hat, dann ist man öfter entspannt, weil man weiß, man könnte klicken, wenn man muss. Man muss ja dann gar nicht, das ist immer das Ding.
Aber, und da noch so dieses... Es gibt ja schon Bedürfnis, was ich habe, was ich probiert habe, durch den Kauf eines MacBooks zu befriedigen, was offensichtlich nicht... Klar, ich nutze es jetzt nicht mehr, weil es nicht funktioniert hat, weil es nicht gut genug ist. Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Apple da mit einem bisschen radikaleren Ansatz durchaus hinkommen könnte. Genau, und träumen von Tablets.
Und wenn es dann kommt, dann sagen wir, sie haben es schon immer gewusst.
Genau.
Ich habe es schon wieder nicht geschafft, über SSDs zu reden.
So ist das. Aber das Thema für die nächste Sendung.
Gibt es aber jetzt neue von Inter, gerade irgendwie.
Ja, das wäre eigentlich ein guter Aufhänger gewesen.
Neue gebaut, Preise gesenkt.
Habt ihr da jetzt umfangreich für dich noch was nachzutrauen?
Nein. Schneller, billiger, fertig.
Okay, dann ist ja alles super. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis bald wieder mal.
Uber Max.